bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat gros plan ce matin sur
les travaux de la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale sur le dopage la semaine
dernière les sénateurs ont entendu
Christian prudom le directeur du Tour de
France audition que je vous propose de
suivre tout de suite Christian prudente
bonjour
merci
d'avoir répondu à l'invitation de cette
commission d'enquête sur le
dopage le caractère particulier de notre
réunion m'invite à être un peu plus
procédural qu'à l'habitude nous avons
l'obligation en effet dans une
commission d'enquête de demander à la
personne que nous recevons de bien
vouloir dire la vérité toute la vérité
et de lever la main droite et dire je le
jure c'est la tradition dans ces
commissions je le jure je vous en
remercie je voudrais indiquer
que si cette audition est
publique les participants non membres de
la
commission ne peuvent à aucun moment
émettre une opinion positive négative
sur ce qui a été dit déclaré par
l'intervenant et que s'agissant d'un
nombre important de journalistes vous
avez bien évidemment la possibilité de
faire votre travail mais c'est pas
pendant la réunion de cette commission
d'enquête que vous pouvez intervenir au
débeautés pour interrompre les travaux
de notre commission je voudrais
remercier mes collègues qui sont
nombreux à participer
aujourd'hui et je voudrais en commençant
Christian prudom vous adresser à titre
personnel des félicitations pour une
distinction que vous avez reçu il y a
peu de temps
merci le déroulement de notre
commission c'est traditionnellement de
laisser la parole pendant un quart
d'heure 20 minutes à celui qui est
auditionné et puis de demander ensuite à
commencer par le
rapporteur de demander ensuite aux
collègues membres de la commission de
bien vouloir eux aussi Inter
l'intervenant donc je vais vous donner
la parole vous avez c'est pas
chronométré avec une précision toute
byzantine je me permets de donner un
caractère local à cette bonne ville vous
avez un quart d'heure 20 minutes ou plus
si nécessaire faudra simplement nous
laisser le temps ensuite de poser toutes
les questions que nous souhaitons vous
poser monsieur prudom vous avez la
parole je suis donc chran prudom je suis
directeur du cyclisme chez amoris Sport
Organisation depuis le 1er février
2007 médiatiquement directeur du Tour de
France j'étais les tris années
précédentes de janvier 2004 à janvier
2007 adjoint successeur potentiel de de
jean-marie- Leblanc après une carrière
de journaliste
professionnel le journalisme est le
métier de ma vie ça reste encore
aujourd'hui le directeur du Tour à ce
jour a quasiment toujours été
journaliste et un jour c'est mon nom qui
est sorti du chapeau et quand on me l'a
proposé Patrice clairire Jean-Marie
Leblanc me l'ont proposé avec la
senentiment de Philippe amoris j'ai dit
oui euh 18 ans de journalisme à la radio
à la télé
essentiellement pour finir euh à France
Télévision comme rédacteur en chef du
service des sports euh j'ai couvert
comme journaliste cinq tours de France
deux en 95 et 96 euh pour Europe 1 et
trois pour France trélévision en 2001
2002 2003 avant d'être adjoint donc
puis puis directeur du Tour à partir de
2007 euh un un un mot peut-être sur sur
ce qu'est un organisateur de compétition
cycliste
puisque les organisateurs de
compétitions cyclistes sont atypiques
dans le monde du
sport nous sommes l'émanation des
journaux qui ont créé les épreuves le
Tour de France a été créé par le journal
loto le Tour d'Italie le Giro a été créé
par par la Gazetta le tour des Flandes
parinis le Critérium du Dauphiné ont
tous été créés par des journaux ça veut
dire donc qu'aujourd'hui dans
l'organisation du monde du cyclisme il y
a une pièce en plus par rapport à
l'essentiel des autres
disciplines naturellement dans ce dans
ce Mondel euh ce sont les fédérations
nationales et internationales qui
détiennent le pouvoir réglementaire et
l'architecture du calendrier euh dans le
cyclisme les seuls événements qui sont
organisés directement par la fédération
ou les fédérations c'est le championnat
de France pour la Fédération française
et les championnats du monde pour la
Fédération internationale de tutelle à
savoir l'Union cycliste internationale
c'est vrai qu'on nimaginerait pas ça
dans le foot avec une coupe du monde qui
ne serait pas organisée par la FIFA la
Fédération internationale par
exemple les fédérations internationales
sont seules qui sont celles qui en
matière de dopage légifèr contrôle et
sanctionne le rôle de l'organisateur lui
dans ce domaine il est de financer en
place la logistique nécessaire au
contrôle le premier rôle de
l'organisateur c'est d'établir les
parcours s'assurer de la sécurité c'est
l'hébergement c'est toute la logistique
chez amoris Sport Organisation vous avez
plusieurs départements le cyclisme est
l'un de ces départements au côté des
sports mécaniques au côté des sport de
masse au côté du golf ou de la voile
nous organisons 100 jours de compétition
cycliste par an ça commence avec le Tour
du Qatar féminin à la fin du mois de
janvier ou au début février ça va
jusqu'à Paris tour à la mi-octobre
làdedans il y a des épreuves en France
et à l'étranger il y a des épreuves dont
ASO et le groupe amoris sont
propriétaires et d'autres pour lesquells
nous sommes simples prestataires de
services je pense notamment autour du
Qatar féminin autour du Qatar ou autour
de Man où nous sommes prestataires c'est
l'organisateur la société qui appartient
à l'ancien champion edimerx qui est
propriétaire et il nous demande pour
avoir le savoir-faire logistique d'O et
les stampis Tour de France d'aller
organiser en France nous organisons le
le parinis au début du mois de mars le
Critérium International qui se déroule
en Corse depuis 4 ans maintenant Paris
roubay c'était dimanche dernier part de
là le pont des classiques ardanais en
Belgique fles Won et li bassolniè
organisons le Tour de Picardie le
Critérium du Dauphiné le Tour de France
et et en fin de saison une nouvelle
course qui s'appelle entre Belgique et
et Pays-Bas la World por classique entre
Rotterdam et enverse une course en
Norvège qui verra sa première édition au
mois d'août nous avons repris la Velta
nous organisons aussi Paris tour et nous
sommes ces dernières de dernières années
nous étions aussi prestataires de
service pour le tour de Pékin
euh notre rôle est plus ou moins
important parfois on est là uniquement
pour installer les les lignes d'arrivée
lignes de départ parfois pour les
courses qui nous appartiennent il faut
évidemment établir le parcours sachant
que par exemple sur un tour de France
nous travaillons sur TR années
consécutives donc les équipes sont en
permanence au contact des élus des
services des collectivités euh pour
faire en sorte que la course puisse
exister et être dans notre jargon
livré j'en
reviens à l'aspect qui nous concerne
directement aujourd'hui à savoir le le
dopage et
l'antidopage le rôle de l'organisateur
dans ce domaine làà donc ben faire en
sorte que les les gens chargés du
contrôle puissent être pris en charge
ces dernières années par exemple sur le
Tour de France vous avez deux équipes de
trois médecins préleveur et deux équipes
de trois agents de contrôle alors c'est
le nouveau vocable la nouvelle
terminolog pour les commissaires de
l'UCI qui viennent voir si tout est fait
dans les règles il y a quelques années
ils étaient beaucoup moins nombreux ils
font maintenant un demi-tour de France
il se partagent les rôles ils arrivent
certains sont au départ vont jusqu'à la
journée de repos et ensuite d'autres
l'une des deux journées de repos et les
autres
reviennent sur les les les liens
j'entends parfois les liens pouvez vous
récuser tel ou tel et cetera euh il n'y
a aucun lien entre l'organisateur et les
coureurs il y a un lien entre
l'organisateur et les équipes euh pas
entre les coureurs sachant que euh euh
le
le le le Tour de France comme la plupart
de nos épreuves étant dans le dans le
classement mondial qui s'appelle ce qui
s'appelle le World Tour dans le jargon
cycliste
euh un certain nombre d'équipes sont
d'ors et déjà qualifiés pour les
épreuves de ce calendrier là euh par
exemple euh les 15 premiers du
classement mondial sont systématiquement
en première division et ensuite trois
équipes classées entre la 16e et la 20e
place d'un classement sportif ou plus ou
moins sportifs euh sont prises et trois
des cinq sont là ce qui fait qu'au
départ d'une course comme le Tour de
France vous avez 18 équipes qui sont
sélectionnées en vérité par la
Fédération internationale et qui sont
donc au départ pour pour l'organisateur
il reste quatre places et même trois
seulement cette année puisque l'Union
cycliste internationale avait souhaité
que l'équipe Katoucha l'équipe russe ne
soit pas dans le World Tour et le
Tribunal Arbitral du Sport lui a donné
Tor donc ils ont été réintégrés ce qui
fait qu'il neous reste plus que trois
places pour les invitations du Tour de
France comme nous n avions plus que si
places au lieu de 7 sur paris-roubayis
par exemple la limite maximale n'étant
pas en nombre d'équipes en nombre de
coureurs le maximum c'est 200 coureurs
donc 22 équipes de 9 comme c'est le cas
pour les grands tours ou 25 équipes de 8
comme c'est le cas pour les classiques
Paris roubay ou Liège bassaniège par
exemple donc pour nous cette année une
invitation de moins 3 lieu de 4 pour le
Tour de France et pour les les
classiques une invitation de moins aussi
donc 6 au lieu de
7 ce n'est pas parce que
euh le Tour de France
euh l'organisateur en général n'a pas
légiférer contrôler et sanctionner en
matière de dopage que ça ne l'intéresse
pas que ça ne le concerne pas d'ailleurs
il faudrait être fou pour ça puisque à
l'évidence le problème numéro 1 du sport
de haut niveau et chez nous aussi c'est
le dopage et l'antidopage enfin c'est le
dopage et donc l'entiopage pour essayer
de de faire en sorte que ça est mieux
euh
nous je vous disais que j'étais devenu
directeur du Tour en en en 2007 je vais
pas vous faire toute l'histoire 2007
c'est aussi la première année où l' cles
mais sur le Tour de France c'est le
général Gilles qui était à l'époque le
patron de la gendarmerie française qui
nous avait dit après le après le Tour
2006 à l'automne faut faire quelque
chose il se passe des choses pas
normales il faut protéger le Tour de
France c'est ce que nous souhaitons donc
nous avons accepté naturellement que
l'OC soit sur le Tour de France je suis
pas convaincu que ça là soit sur
beaucoup d'autres épreuves en France ni
même d'ailleurs a l'équivalent dans
d'autres disciplines sportives et ce
sont mais vous avez entendu je crois
trois personnes donc il le savent bien
évidemment beaucoup mieux que moi mais
d'un point de vue formel et de
logistique ce sont six personnes qui
sont attachées autour pendant 3 semaines
et une dizaines qui sont qui bougent qui
suivant les régions ou les départements
sont là chaque soir pour voir ce qui se
passe ou ce qui ce qui ne se passe pas
d'ailleurs 2008 c'est une année
particulière euh on est en en en pleine
BAGAR avec l'Union cycliste
internationale grâce au soutien de la
Fédération Française de Cyclisme
notamment de son président de l'époque
Jean pitalier le tour est organisé le
tour sort de de tout le le le de tout le
caneva officiel du sport mondial se
place sous l'gy de la Fédération
française c'est l'Agence française de
lutte contre le dopage
qui s'occupe des contrôles alors
certains diront avec une réussite
formidable
euh je veux simplement et c'est vrai
d'un point de vue d'un point de vue
efficacité de la lutte sans le moindre
doute mais en revanche d'un point de vue
médiatique on ne peut pas dire que
chaque poureur qui souhaitait prendre
était considéré par la presse comme une
victoire des organisateurs du Tour sur
dans la lutte contre le depage c'était
pas exactement comme ça que ça se
passait au contraire on prenait un coup
de bâton à chaque fois et pourtant
c'était
peut-être on s souvent le sentiment que
quand vous n'êtes pas enfin si vous êtes
un équivalent policier ou gendarme en
fait plus vous arrêtez de gens plus vous
faites taper dessus quoi c'est un peu
schizophrène enfin peu porte il est
décidé par le groupe décision politique
du groupe durant l'été 2008 de de mettre
fin à la guerre j'entendais moi-même
dire d'ailleurs des gens de tous
horizons et amoureux du vélo vous êtes
vraiment complètement fous dans le
cyclisme il y a déjà le dopage et en
plus vous vous tapez dessus sans arrêt
il faut vraiment que ça cesse ce n'est
pas possible il y a donc eu des réunions
au niveau du groupe je n'y a pas
participé et et une paix a été scellée
et peu après cette paix et est arrivé
parce que c'était essentiel pour nous le
passeport sanguin qui n'est pas la
panacée mais qui pour moi sans aucun
doute a fait vraiment avancer les choses
à tel point qu'aujourd'hui d'autres
fédérations l'utilisent je pense à
l'athlétisme ou ce qui de fond et et
récemment la Fédération internationale
de tennis a indiqué qu'elle allait elle
aussi utiliser le passeport outil
essentiel pour cibler je crois que c'est
le plus important mais aussi pour
sanctionner certains cyclistes
alors pas forcément des cador mais un
certain nombre de cyclistes ont été
depuis sanctionnés par ce biaet et ça
donne là aussi une possibilité
supplémentaire de de
travail je je je vais passer à à à à
l'automne dernier et à 2012 à ce que
nous avons alors il il y a plein
d'autres choses entre il a on va devant
le TASS en mars 2009 parce que nous ne
souhaitons pas que l'équipe soier du Val
soit au départ du Tour de France on
gagne on va vantass après laaffaire
bononne parce que devant non c'était le
tribunal de grande instance de nanère
euh il avait été sanctionné
et à moitié sanctionné
euh pour une prise de quétesse la
cigarette qui fait rire pardonnez-moi du
du surnom euh nous avons perdu euh et
est ce que je voulais simplement vous
dire sur le tas c'est que j'ai été très
frappé par euh ce qu'on pu me dire les
ce qu'a pu me dire le le président du
tribunal la séance a duré 8h et pour moi
45 secondes avec trois questions en
vérité trois fois la même vous êtes qui
le Tour de France vous êtes qui
amispganisation vous êtes qui une
société anonyme merci Monsieur ce qui
replçit aussi bien les choses dans leur
contexte il n'empêche que là-dessus nous
avons gagné il n'était pas au départ du
Tour de France nous avions perdu 2 ans
plus tôt face à Astana euh nous ne
voulions pas qu'il soit au départ le
tribunal le tas nous a donné tort mais
comme un certain nombre de coureurs ont
été pris par ailleurs dans l'affaire
Puerto en fait il n'était pas assez
nombreux au départ et quand vous n'êtes
que ça il peuvent pas être au départ
c'est le règlement de l'ci mais on avait
formellement perdu devant le TASS en en
en octobre en octobre 2012 lors de la
présentation du Tour en octobre dernier
j'ai insisté sur le fait que les
managers d'équipe étaient la clé il y a
des managers formidables il y en a qui
sont moins
euh le poisson pourri par la tête
euh quand on parle de changement de
génération c'est pas un changement de
génération de
coureur si les managers qui sont là euh
sont toujours les mêmes et managers on
peuTent rester plus longtemps que courur
cycliste professionnel ou que sportif de
niveau il faut il faut absolument et on
ne pourra pas progresser tant que les
gens qui sont dans l'entourage médecin
manager à un moment ou à un autre ne
trinuent pas aussi et ne sont pas
poursuivis aussi c'est une certitude
c'est c'est pour ça que j'ai parlé du
mouvement pour un cyclisme crédible qui
n'est pas le paradis sur terre qui ne
prétend d'ailleurs pas offrir le paradis
sur terre mais qui se met des règles
beaucoup plus sévères beaucoup plus
draconiennes que les propres règles du
code mondial antiopage alors depuis que
j'ai annoncé ça en octobre les effectifs
ont été multipliés par tro ou qu je ne
suis pas totalement dupe sur le fait que
certains veulent surtout se dire tiens
voilà puis que le tour veut ça hein et
et et par le fait que j'ai pu annoncer
que les invitations que nous offrons
dans toutes nos courses celle de Paris
roubé il y a 3 jours comme celle du Tour
de France ne serait donné qu'à des
équipes qui sont membres du cyclisme du
mouvement pour un cyclisme crédible mais
c'est un élément absolument
essentiel nous souhaitons aussi
naturellement mais c'est beaucoup plus
facile à dire qu'à faire qu'un organisme
indépendant et vraiment indépendant gère
l'antidopage c'est absolument capital
vous mettez 12 sein ensemble dans une
salle vous les laissé pendant quelques
années il y en a forcément un qui trahit
donc il faut forcément de la de l'air il
faut pouvoir respirer et il faut donc
que ce soit des gens qui n'ont rien à
voir avec ce monde-là qui gère dans tous
les pays et pour toutes les disciplines
sur la même
règle une question m'ta été posée à
Pierre bordri qui vous avez entendu
quelques jours mais qui est là
aujourd'hui aussi tout à l'heure quand
nous étions dehors euh m'était posé
aussi sur le l'aspect international
c'estàdire que on peut faire tout ce
qu'on veut dans un pays quel que soit le
pays si le pays est seul et que ailleurs
c'est pas la même chose ça n'est pas
possible ça n'est pas
possible sur le mouvement pour un
cyclisme crédible par exemple les
coureurs de les coureurs français de
tous les groupes français les coureurs
français des groupes étrangers sont
soumis à certaines choses ils sont
contraint de le faire les étrangers
d'autres équipes comme l'équipe
néerlandaise Argos par exemple s'y
soumettent mais mais ce les autres ne
sont pas oblés de s'y soumettre parce
que c'est simplement leur choix ils
respectent le code mondial antidopage il
y a rien à leur dire ils ne trichent pas
simplement ils ne se disent pas faut
aller encore encore plus loin parce que
le vélo a la nécessité de reconquérir sa
crédibilité l'action policière
judiciaire j'évoquéis tout à l'heure l'
laes la gendarmerie la police les
douanes ils sont évidemment
essentiels avec une une une vraie
différence ces dernières années
c'est-à-dire que très longtemps seul les
douanes seul la police seul la
gendarmerie trouver des gens qui
trichait aujourd'hui depuis 2006 il y a
aussi le pouvoir sportif lui-même quand
on dit que les contrôles ne marchent pas
ils sont sûrement pas parfait mais je
crois bien avoir entendu que le
vainqueur du Tour 2006 et le vainqueur
du Tour 2010 ont été convaincus de deux
pages ça veut donc malgré tout dire que
ça existe et ça a été le cas aussi
d'ailleurs pour le Tour d'Espagne pour
le Tour d'Italie
euh il y a une demi-douzaine d'années
donc un vrai progrès fait là-dessus je
crois aussi que sans l'aide des
laboratoires il y a pas de
solution il faut avoir des gens qui
savent sur les nouveaux produits sur
toutes les rumeurs qu'on peut entendre
sur tel ou tel produit qui serait
utilisé qui a jamais été testé qui sont
une véritable
folie voilà je suis à votre
disposition merci
pour cette intervention
liminaire la règle du jeu dans notre
commission d'enquête c'est qu'après
l'intervenant ce soit le rapporteur
plutôt qui commence à poser les
premières questions donc je donne la
parole à jean-jacqueszac notre
rapporteur bien merci monsieur le
président monsieur le le directeur du
Tour de France je crois que vous avez en
face de vous me semble-t-il des des
passionnés de sport et je dirais même
des amoureux du du Tour de France et qui
considèr donc cette épreuve très
populaire comme appartenant comme on le
dit très souvent notre patrimoine
national et nous avons toujours essayé
nous continuerons à le faire d'avoir un
traitement je dirais équitable entre
toutes les disciplines sportives en tout
cas c'est l'une des ambitions exprimées
par not notre commission d'enquête
parlementaire donc il s'agit pas de
faire de telle ou telle activité
sportive en l'occurrence ce cyclisme une
sorte de bouc émissaire hein mais il
s'agit pas non plus de dédoiner telle ou
telle activité de cette problématique et
en particulier de cette réalité tout à
fait condamnable qui est l'usage de
produits illicites comme les produits
d'pan mais parce qu'on aime bien on est
aussi
exigeant exigeant d'autant plus que vous
savez les sénateurs sont tous où ont été
où le seront des élus locaux donc nous
avons tous eu l'occasion je crois à un
moment ou un autre de recevoir le Tour
de France sur nos territoires respectifs
dans nos villes sur nos départements ou
sur nos régions donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous allons vous poser un
certain nombre de de questions très
précises parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a
quand même un lien particulier entre ce
que certains appellent la culture du
dopage et puis d'autre part le cyclisme
vous savez ce que disait déjà en 1894
Henri Desgranges donc c'est ça remonte
très loin dans dans l'histoire et sur ce
problème du du dopage nous avons
auditionné en particulier un ancien
ministre des Sports je fais référence à
lui puisqu'il a cité justement le le
Tour de France et il nous a affirmé que
les organisateurs d'événements étaient
forcément au courant des
pratiques alors vous êtes aujourd'hui
sous sous serment Monsieur le Directeur
est-ce que vous pouvez is affirmer que
vous n'avez jamais reçu d'éléments
sérieux sur l'usage de produits dopan
par certains sportifs ou par certaines
équipes et si vous les avez reçu les
avez-vous immédiatement transmis aux
autorités françaises je n'en ai jamais
reçu
d'accord par ailleurs vous avez donc
succédé à à Patrice CLIRE donc non non
non Patrice était mon patron j'ai
succédé à Jean-Marie leblinc et c'est
aujourd'hui Jean-Étienne amoris qui est
qui est et qui a le rôle qu' avait à
l'époque Patrice est-ce que parce que
donc il y a eu semble-t-il des des
divergences d'opinion et puis c'est vrai
que vous étiez je crois notamment en ce
qui concerne les orientations en matière
de lutte contre le dopage proche de de
Patrice claire est-ce qu'il y a eu dans
la stratégie d' d'assaut une sorte de de
réorientation de
d'infléchissement en matière de lutte
antiopage au cours de ces dernières
années ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'est que c'est que le groupe a
décidé décision politique durant l'été
2008 de cesser la guerre il y avait 4
ans de guerre et moi-même à titre
personnel j'ai entendu des personnes et
pas une seule me dire je vous répète ce
que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure mais
mais vous êtes complètement fou vous
avez déjà les problèmes de page et en
plus vous tapez dessus donc vraiment
votre sport ça va finir comme la boxe il
y aura plus rien si vous continuez comme
ça donc la décision du groupe a été
on on revient dans le giron du sport
mondial comme toutes les autres
disciplines sachant et et vous le savez
aussi que la Fédération Française avait
été sanctionnée qu' avait menace sur les
athlètes français de ne pas participer
au championnat du monde qui avait même
une menace sur les Jeux Olympiques
disant ils n'iront pas parce que voilà
le Tour de France est fâché avec nous la
Fédération Française ça a été dur avec
la Fédération Française qui nous a
soutenu jusqu'au bout notamment Jean
Jean pitalier sans sans lui et sans la
Fédération on a'aurait jamais pu
organiser il y aurait pas eu de Tour de
France en 2008 donc on avait bien
conscience aussi que c'était pas
simplement ce qu'on pensait nous mais
qu'on risquait de mettre en péril toute
la discipline parce que nous on devait
commencer à se justif de attendez mais
c'est bien ce que vous faites mais on va
pas faire les championnats du monde à
cause de vous on va pas y aller au les
Olympiques alors qu'en fait on est on
sortait du du du schéma classique de
tout le sport mondial tout le sport
mondial est organisé comme ça et on en
est sorti et à un moment bah fallait
bien y rentrer et à ce moment-là le
le j'étais pas dans les discussions moi
du groupe he mais un élément essentiel
pour ce qui me concerne c'est qu'à ce
moment-là luucmi a mis en place ce
fameux passeport biologique qui n'a pas
tout de suite servi sur le Tour 2008
Tour 2008 c'était juste avant puisque
Patrice était encore là et et ensuite à
la rentré donc il y a une mise en place
du passeport qui est un élément
absolument essentiel et qui montrait
qu'on était peut-être sur une autre voie
de lutte aussi contre le dopage avec une
fédération qui n'avait peut-être pas
fait ce qu'il fallait avant mais qui
entrait dans un autre dans un autre
cheminement je passe la parle parole à
notre collègue Alain nie puis
Jean-Claude Carles Alain nry je vous
demande mon cher collègue quel que soit
l'intérêt comme à chaque fois de vos
interventions essayz oui on va faire
court moi ce qui me la question que je
me pose c'est
effectivement de la crédibilité des
résultats sur le Tour de France donc on
est tous des des des gens qui aimont le
sport et le le cyclisme en particulier
tout à l'heure vous l' le Tour de France
c'est un monument dans le domaine
sportif
moi je rappelle toujours que je souhaite
que le Tour de France soit organisé tous
les ans puisque les années où il a pu
été organisé c'était des années de
guerre
donc mais il y a quand même une chose
qui m'interpelle c'est que aujourd'hui
il y a des contrôles et pourtant si on
en croit les commentaires et si on en
croit nos yeux on s'aperçoit que il
semblerait que le le dopage so en recul
et pourtant les performances restent les
mêmes sinon supérieures c'estàd que
quand je vois par que le 15e d'une étape
du Tour monte le dernier col aussi vite
que le vainqueur 10 ans avant je
m'interroge quand même sur la sur
l'efficacité de notre lutte contre le
dopage qui est d'ailleurs le titre même
de notre commission monsieur le
Président alors on n pas forcément la
même vision
pardon on n pas forcément la même
vision on se réfère souvent à la moyenne
générale du Tour de France il y a un
seul coureur qui a fait le tour à plus
de 42 il s'appelle l Samsung euh il a
couru aussi à 41 de moyenne et cetera
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt à 39800 et
cetera un petit 40 faut se méfier des
moyennes générales vous avez une étape
de pleine extrêmement rapide une étape
de pleine extrêmement lente ça influe
sur la moyenne générale du Tour de
France et ça veut pas forcément dire
grand-chose en revanche j'ai pas du tout
les mêmes chiffres sur les montées
euh sur la montée de l'Alpe d'est
notamment gagné par Pierre Rolland en
2011 il aurait été dans les chou les
années précédentes il a le 24e temps de
la montée
Pierre Rolland en 2011 c'est qu'il est
monté 4 minutes plus lentement que Marco
Pantani il est monté mon en 4210 Pierre
Rolland pantan doit avoir un record
alors c'est c'est pas toujours pareil
parce que il y a des chronométrages qui
étaient fait à certains moment à 14 km
500 de la ligne d'autres maintenant sont
fait précisément à 13900 ciroped de la
montée Armstrong a gagné sonstrong gagné
en 2001 en 3801 pierreolland a gagné en
4210 a gagné l'étape de Morzine 2006 200
km à 36 de moyenne Roland a gagné la
tousire à 315 bon alors on peut trouver
les exemples sûrement dans l'autre sens
aussi si les gens cherchent et cetera
mais
mais il y a pas il y a pas la
progression assurément dans le cyclisme
depuis une douzaine d'années qu'on peut
voir dans notre sport et dans d're
domaine voilà et sans jeter le le probre
à qui que ce soit dans dans d'autes
domaines on n pas battu l'équivalent du
record du 100 m dans le Tour de France
ces dernières années merci Jean-Claude
Carles sénateur de haute savoir les
grandes épreuves de cyclisme sont
organisées par un organisateur il est
pour la plupart des plus prestigieuses
par la zoo contrairement à d'autres
disciplines où c'est les fédérations
nationales ou international qui en sont
l'organisateur alors est-ce que jeais
dire cette structure ou cette
configuration fait que d'une part on
focalise peut-être plus sur le cyclisme
en terme de de de dopage alors qu' on
l'a vu au cours des auditions qu'on a
fait d'autres sports sont concernés et
même en terme de résultats positifs sont
même parfois devant le cycliste
peut-être avec d'autres produits mais ça
n'est pas le fait uniquement du cycl et
deuxièmement est-ce que justement cette
interface qui est l'organisateur ça
n'est pas soit un frein à la lutte ou ça
peut être aussi un accélérateur si vous
voulez le fond de ma pensée tout le
sport devrait être organisé comme ça
mais vu les ennuis que nous avons
personne ne veut que ce soit comme ça
parce que nous ne sommes pas jugés
partis nous ne sommes pas jugés partis
nous ne faisons pas les règles nous
n'établissons pas le nombre de contrôle
nous ne disons pas un tel ou un tel doit
être
contrôlé et le problème c'est que quand
vous voyez ce qui nous arrive qui a
envie que ce soit comme ça
ailleurs je ne dis pas que le cyclisme
n'a jamais triché je répète bien ça le
cyclisme a triché avant les autres plus
plus loin que les autres et cetera mais
mais mais ça a changé l'une des vraies
difficultés dans le sport cycliste c'est
qu'on n'est pas dans une lutte
internationale c'est qu'après fain 98
seule la France a arrêté après il a
fallu que dans chaque pays une affaire
pour qu'ils arrêtent à leur tour jusqu'à
l'affaire Puerto en 2006 Yanou rich en
Allemagne est un héros aujourd'hui
cétait un brûlé c'est-à-dire que puero
c'est 2006 c'est 8 ans après festin
c'est qu'il n'avait rien compris c'estd
que leur problème c'était festin c'était
pas leur problème et et le monde du vélo
a commis une erreur terrible à ce
moment-là de dire seu fis signatrich
alors que c'était gangrainé de partout
mais mais mais dans le monde duc c'est
assez drôle c'estd c'est drôle assez
curieux en ce qui concerne le dopage
chacun se dit dans son pays ah non mais
moi les gars de mon pays évidemment qui
triche pas la médaille elle est belle et
dans sa discipline ah non discipline on
triche pas cannabis ça sert à rien oui
mais ça dépend ce que vous faites tout
est adapté à tout ce que Jean-Pierre
Mondenard vous disait avec une vraie
pertinence d'ailleurs
mais il s'y
connaî bah oui vous pouvez trouver tout
ce que vous voulez quel que soit la
discipline pour faire en sorte que vous
soyez meilleur donc moi je crois au
contraire que le fait que nous nous
c'est c'est le tour est un géant et le
tour est un géant médiatique aussi bien
sûr donc le moindre truc sur le Tour
directeur général du Tour de France
c'est pas ce que j'ai sur ma fiche de
pay je suis directeur des cycliste CHEO
c'est qu'on met des généraux partout
parfois je suis directeur général d'ISO
je MRE bientôt directeur général du
groupe ou je sais pas quoi c'est que
c'est c'est ça c'est médiatique je ne
dis encore une fois je je je ne surtout
taper sur les médias le journalisme et
les métier de ma vie après il y a des
approximations il y a des choses comme
ça voilà monsieur bandri vous parlez
l'autre l'autre jour l'autre jour de la
course Cholet anger comptant sans doute
pour la le championnat de France enfin
c'est le Grand Prix de Cholet pay Loire
qui compte pour la Coupe de France ou le
tour de l'eau vous l'aurez rectifié
c'est le tour de l'AUE
voilà faut faut des choses précises mais
en revanche le fait qu'il un
organisateur bah
oui
nous-même on n'est pas jugé parti on on
devrait sortir de tout mais mais c'est
impossible c'est-à-dire ne même pas
entendre la moindre rumeur à la limite
ne pas lire les journaux ce qui est
évidemment pas possible mais qu'il y ait
cette stratatin en plus c'est plutôt une
garantie pour le sport mais ça crée
quelques
ennuis merci Dominique baayi
oui monsieur le directeur
général je voudrais avoir votre avis
vous avez parlé du passeport biologique
des et des contrôles sanguins qui qui
sont une avancée pour le suivi des
coureurs en particulier le passeport
biologique moi depuis quelques temps je
travaille un peu sur ce dossier et j'ai
appris qu'il existait le profil de
puissance record est-ce que vous le
connaissez puisque certaines équipes se
l'appliquent une en France en
particulier la franceç S des jeux j'ai
sous les yeux un rapport euh bon lors
d'une audition précédente on a un peu
balayé d'un revers de manche mon
intervention on m'a demande en disant ou
tout ça c'est enfin moi je lis c'est le
le docteur enfin l'entraîneur Frédéric
grab qui est entraîneur de la Française
des jeux depuis 2000 quand même quand
même il y a même des équipes
australiennes qui qui mettent ça en
place et qui dit que le PPR est une arme
fatale contre enfin n'est pas une arme
fatale contre le dopage à 100 % mais une
arme fatale pour le suivi du coureur et
ça évite ça éviterait qu'un jour un
manager général d'une équipe dise je ne
savais pas c'est impossible bref c'est
de voir que les limites physiques bien
sûr qu'on progresse humainement
physiquement mais on peut pas passer de
1 à 1000 à un moment donné ça c'est pas
possible on peut pas être un coureur
moyen et monter un col l'année suivante
donc est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
généraliser ce process qui permettrait
comme le passeport biologique et que
d'abord aussi labellisé par luuci parce
que je suis d'accord avec vous si ça se
fait en France et ça se fait pas partout
ça n'a aucun sens mais est-ce que vous
connaissez ce process et vous en pensez
quoi alors je je le connais parce que
parce que je connais bien sûr Frédéric
grapp qui est un monsieur très bien bien
j'en pense plutôt du bien
euh maintenant c'est comme tout c'est il
faut évidemment vous le disiez que ce
soit la même chose partout mais que
d'une équipe à une autre il faut qu'ils
aient exactement le même système et que
tous les jours les machines soient
étalonnées parce que le le le le le
comment vous dire
euh établir la puissance à partir de la
télévision en regardant les courses et
cetera je je suis pas que ce soit je
suis pas du tout scientifique moi mais
je suis pas certain que ce soit
extraordinairement scientifique me dire
attends je l'ai vu oui mais alors le
vent il était comment mais la pente
est-ce que c'était bien ça est-ce qu' a
marqué est-ce que la pente c'est ce qui
a marqué sur le panneau fait par le
conseil général ou c'est ce qui a marqué
sur le livre de route bon en revanche en
revanche en revanche ce que ce que ce
que fré gra fait est évidemment un
élément important mais encore une fois
on ne peut pas gagner seul ou progresser
seul dans les comp de page donc il faut
que tout soit
généralisé une chose qui me paraît
essentielle et que j'oubl de dire tout à
l'heure euh plusieurs médecins d'équipe
m'ont parlé de ça DEP depuis plusieurs
années c'est l'aspect santé quand Floyd
Landis c'est au départ du Tour 2006 et
qu'un certificat médical lui dit vous
pouvez être au départ du tour alors
qu'il a une histoire de protèse deche
c'est tout simplement pas possible on ne
dit pas qu'il triche simplement ce n'est
pas possible de faire le tour de France
dans ces conditions-là et aujourd'hui
ces choses-là on ne peut pas les imposer
ou on pourrait les imposer mais
uniquement aux Français ce qui n'a pas
de sens sur la première course cycliste
mondiale l' 10 Nura jamais dû être au
départ du Tour de France peut pas être
au départ d'une épreuve qui est dure
bien sûr c'est ce qui fait sa
légende et et et là-dessus c'est un
élément essentiel on n'a jamais pu
avancer là-dessus la médecine de santé
monsieur non on est désolé mais c'est
pas possible est- que vous
pensez
attendez mon cher collègue monsieur
prudent va vous répondre mais on va
essayer d'organiser un peu les choses ça
sera mieux on parlera des aut un peu
plus tard je suis obligé de respecter
l'inscription de nos collègues Stéphane
Mazard
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Directeur vous avez rappelé quel
était le rôle de l'organisateur donc et
d'ailleurs vous avez dit que selon vous
c'était un bon système
finalement mais d'après vous qui c'est
qui doit garantir auprès du public des
téléspectateurs des
spectateurs un principe d'équité
sportive est-ce que là pour le coup en
tant qu'organisateur vous avez pas une
responsabilité qui peut peut-être demain
euh pousser peut-être euh votre
responsabilité également dans dans le
suivi de cette équité sportive et le
métien de cette équité sportive plus
loin bien sûr qu'on a une responsabilité
mais
euh j'ai devant moi un bouton j'imagine
que si j'appuie dessus je le coupe et
vous ne m'entendez plus l'organisateur
aujourd'hui dans le monde du sport ne
peut pas appuyer sur le bouton c'est pas
qu'il le qu'il le souhaite ou qu'il ne
le souhaite pas il n'a pas accès au
bouton et en vérité c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure l'URE avec le
Tribunal arbitral du sport c'est qu'à un
moment nous n'avons pas la
délégation et je pense qu'on doit pas
l'avoir même si médiatiquement
évidemment qu'on est responsable c'est
normal consid en tout cas considéré
comme tel c'est pas prudeomme qui veut
pas appuyer sur le bouton pour lutter
contre le deage on n'a pas accès au
bouton on peut pas l'approcher c'est pas
justement là les les limites du système
c'està-dire que demain est-ce que vous
êtes pas la merci je sais pas moi d'une
action de groupe on verra ce que la loi
sur la consommation va faire mais de
téléspectateurs floué qui vont venir
vous demander des comptes sur des étapes
du Tour de France qu'ils ont suivi et
puis un an après on leur dit mais non
mais tout ça c'était pour de
faux donc est-ce que c'est pas là les
les limites du d'un organisateur qui à
la fois n'a pas les moyens de tout
mettre en œuvre pour garantir aux
spectateurs que l'équité sportive elle
est respectée pour tout garantir et tout
mettre en œuvre il faut un autre système
du sport mondial
ou alors il faut très clairement que le
que
le ce que nous souhaitons d'ailleurs que
qu'un organisme totalement indépendant
dans toutes les discipline et dans tous
les pays fonctionne et traite le dopage
et l'antidopage enfin
l'antidopage merci je vais donner la
parole maintenant à Michel
Savin sénateur de liser euh merci monsur
président mon monsieur leur vous nous
avez dit tout à l'heure que euh euh ce
qui à vos yeux était euh peut-être une
des choses les
les plus difficile à gérer c'est
l'entourage même du du coureur et
notamment le manager qui est la clé même
du problème alors ce discours nous
l'avons déjà entendu euh lors de
précédentes audition euh lorsqu'on nous
a expliqué que souvent
l'entourage qui des équipes
professionnelles fermer les yeux euh euh
aussi bien au moment des courses au
moment des des contrôles ou organiser
euh mettre en place certaines barrières
euh ce qui a pour conséquence la
difficulté aussi des contrôles même
pendant les courses donc on voit bien
que cet entourage est ciblé par vous
mais aussi par d'autres organismes qui
sont là pour contrôler en terme de de
contrôle de dopage qui peut prendre des
sanctions auprès de sur cet entourage
est-ce que c'est l'organisateur est-ce
que c'est la Fédération Française est-ce
que c'est la Fédération Internationale
est-ce qu'un
travail est en cours oui pour essayer de
de de mettre en place ce travail
attendez j'ai pas pardon monsieur
sénateur je vous en PR et toujours parce
que c'est un point aussi qui nous a
beaucoup interpellé alors là c'est c'est
ça va un petit peu à
l'inverse vous nous dites et beaucoup
nous ont dit que c'était l'entourage qui
était à l'origine ou qui courager
peut-être on nous a aussi beaucoup dit
que le cyclisme était très touché par le
dopage au niveau amateur et encore plus
inquiétant au niveau des jeunes et nment
après des jeunes qui ont l'ambition de
passer pro et et alors là je pense pas
alors tous n'ont pas encore des managers
mais ils ont des éducateurs et même pire
quand je dis pire c'est que souvent on
nous a aussi expliquer que même
l'entourage familial fermer les yeux ou
encourager même des fois la la prise le
produits de Pan pour permettre aux
jeunes d'accéder à un niveau pour
rentrer dans une équipe pro donc là
c'est bien la Fédération donc est-ce que
c'est des relations ce travaill est
entrepris pour essayer de trouver une
parade à ce milieu qui est autour du
courur parce que il est vrai aussi que
peut-être que les coureurs s'il n'avaent
pas cette pression peut-être serait
moins tenté de prendre des produits de
Pan alors il y a il y a hélas oui bien
sûr une culture de de page dans le
cyclisme on le sait tous et j'ai
moi-même été interpellé un jour par un
quelqu'un qui avait un peu trop bu et
qui m'a dit manière très véante vous n'y
arrierez
jamais vous n'y arriverez jamais bon euh
ça m'a marqué euh maintenant dans dans
dans ce que les décisions qui ont été
prises par l'UC ces dernières années il
y en a une excellente qui
malheureusement n'est pas rétroactive
c'est le fait que quand un coureur est
contrôlé positif et sanctionné de plus
de 6 mois il ne peut plus être manager
derrière il ne peut pas appartenir à une
équipe mais ça c'est récent c'est je
crois au 1er janvier 2011 c'estàd que
tous ceux d'avant ne peuvent pas venir
une année nous n'avons pas accrédité BN
r un des managers sur le Tour de France
ben siil voulez aller à l'hôtel il all à
l'hôtel si vou avec son ordinateur il
avec son ordinateur si vous vouit être
avec son téléphone portable il est avec
son téléphone portable on l'a pas
accrédité oui mais qu'est-ce que ça
change nous on ne pouvait que ne pas
l'accréditer je vous concè que c'est pas
très très
efficace après on on fait quoi le danger
c'est toujours que c'est c'est c'est
devant c'est qu'on dit alors on revient
pas et et quand on parle de changement
de génération sur un changement de
génération de managers qu'il faudrait
quand je dis le manager et la clé il y a
des gens qui sont formidables il y a des
gens exceptionnels et qui se battent et
qui se font engueuler tous les jours
doper doper doper alors que se battent
sainement depuis des années et des
années et qui sont terriblement frustrés
j'ai j'ai j'ai entendu un manager je
peux je peux le j'étais journaliste à
l'époque je commentais les championnats
du monde à Hamilton en en 2003 au Canada
et le hasard a fait que j'ai pris le
petit déjeuner avec Alain Bondu qui a
été ensuite qui était manager de
l'équipe cofid 10 qui été sanctionné qui
est passé par la case prison et il m'a
dit au petit-déjeuner mon Coutier n'a
rien compris mon Coutier n'a rien
compris quand moi j'ai appris 4 ou 5
mois plus tard ou 6 mois plus tard qu'
qu' mondu était quand j'ai entendu à la
radio qu'il était donc emprisonné quand
laa faire cofidi a éclaté ça a sonné
dans ma tête montcoutier n'a rien
compris oui il faut se battre pour des
gens comme David montcoutier à qui on a
volé leur carrière sans aucun
doute merci Alain nry avait envie que
vous nous parliez des aut il peut
brièvement compléter sa question bien
sûr et puis on repassera au rapporteur
ensuite oui brièvement vous n avez dit à
juste titre que l'IS juste titre que
l'andis aurait pasêtre du part du Tour
puisqu dans un état médical qui juste
qui s'il avait été réel n'aurait pas
autorisé à prendre les partart du Tour
et donc je m'interroge sur le fait que
on autorise il y a une autorisation à
usage thérapeutique d'un certain nombre
de produits dont on sait à l'évidence
que vu le grand nombre de concurrents
qui les utilisent qui sont quand même
pas tous malades comme ça sinon c'est
très intéressant 80 % des asmatiques au
Jeux Olympiques on souhaitre
asmatique pas vous répondre monsieur
sénateur si ce n'est vous dire que je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous j'ai
les mêmes conclusion
vous
même si en France je sais je l'ai appris
grâce à vous d'ailleurs en écoutant
l'une des auditions Jean-Pierre Verdi
vous expliquit que il y a trois experts
quand on demande une aut si le médecin
un référent dit là il y a un problème
ils sont trois Ilah faudrait que ce soit
comme ça partout mais attention aussi
c'est ce n'est pas parce que nous sommes
français on parle de la France qu'on est
nous des par de vertu et que tous les
autres sont des
tricheurs et vice
vera notre collègue
lequne merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur donc vous avez dit
une chose très intéressante qui nous
éclaire un peu mais qui nous montre la
complexité énorme pour la lutte contre
le dopage parce qu'il faut se renouveler
tout le temps il y a des produits
nouveaux qui arrivent j'imagine qu'il
n'y a pas forcément non plus les moyens
d'avoir suffisamment de de contrôle et
je voulais savoir si bien que le
projecteur c'est sur le France tout
toute la population regarde ça de très
très près les médias est-ce que au
niveau des des classiques d'une journé
on est a est-ce qu'il y a autant de
dopage sur une journée de course que sur
une course qui dure 21 jours est-ce que
chez les amateurs c'est mesurer un peu
est-ce que vous avez une
idée de du du mal réalisé don par par au
niveau des amateurs et nos écoes de
cyclisme nos jeunes qu'on envoie dans
nos écoles de cyclisme parce que j'ai
entendu avec d'autres gens qu'on a
auditionné que également les jeunes
étaient touchés comme l'a dit collègue
Savin que des parents ou éducateurs N
était un peu coupable dans cette façon
d'éduquer nos jeunes est-ce que est-ce
qu'on peut irradier donc le le dopage
sans sans s'occuper de la jeunesse c'est
quand même eux qui qui sont les
concoureurs de demain donc c'est une
lutte à tous les niveaux à tous les
étages et ça me paraît extrêmement
compliqué mais donc je pense que amateur
et jeunesse c'est indispensable de
regarder ça de très près l'aspect
éducation est bien sûr capital euh sans
le moindre doute alors sur les
classiques je peux pas vous répondre
pour les jeunes j'entends comme vous les
amateurs mais je suis pas le président
de la Fédération Française de Cyclisme
donc je peux pas vous vous vous répondre
là-dessus rche oui je lis comme vous je
regarde comme vous je m'intéresse comme
vous
évidemment sur les sur les les
classiques la Fédération Internationale
stipule qu'il doit y avoir trois
contrôles par classique tris contrôles
antidopage le soir sur Paris rouet
dimanche il y en a eu 6 sur les les
épreuves par étape c'est qure contrôles
par jour s'il y a qure contrôles par
jour sur un tour de France par exemple
ça fait plus ou moins sans contrôle il y
en a plus de
550 et et et d'ailleurs il y avait moins
de contrôle autrefois jusqu'en 2007 ça a
augmenté ensuite parce que la FLD encore
une fois avait fait à l'époque un boulot
remarquable et
nous nous avons souhaité et obtenu
ensuite que ça reste au même niveau de
contrôle c'est c'est multiplié par 5 par
rapport à ce que
demande l'organisation du sport mondial
sachant que ces dernières années il y a
eu une évolution des contr urinaires
vers les contrôles sanguins donc sur les
550 contrôle 2008 il j'ai les chiffres à
votre disposition bien sûr mais mais
mais il y a il y a une bascule c'est il
y avait un maximum de contrôle urinaire
désormais il y a un maximum de contrôle
sanguin donc ça c'est la réalité mais on
est à CIN fois ce qui est demandé par
par les textes et et et donc bien sûr
qu'on pourra enfin on pourrait il
pourrait en faire encore plus
mais le ciblage est essentiel
essentiel merci euh vous aviez terminé
monsieur Prom la réponse oui pardon
monsieur le rapporteur et après
oui Monsieur le Directeur il y a donc un
organisme qui bien sûr joue un rôle
pivot un rôle central dans cette lutte
antidopage c'est laain association
mondiale
antidopage et euh cette agence cette
agence elle est parfois présente sur le
Tour de France et c'est vrai qu'elle
peut mettre à disposition ou en tout cas
faire venir sur les étapes du Tour de
France des des observate
des observateurs indépendants qui
peuvent jouer un rôle un rôle utile de
de conseil de prévention et cetera or
semble-t-il depuis 2003 ces observateurs
de Lama n'ont été présents que une seule
fois c'est-à-dire en
2010 est-ce que à vos yeux il serait
utile de les associer davantage au
déroulement de de de cette épreuve
est-ce que les les les recommandations
de de Lama ont été véritablement suivis
d' faits du côté d'assau
oui alors je pense qu'il y a eu
uniquement 2003 et 2010 hein je pense
que c'est c'est c'est uniquement deux
fois euh moi ce dont je rêve c'est
d'uneama avec des bras c'est pour ça que
j'ai dit depuis 2003 c'est une ama avec
des bras et je pense que c'est pour ça
que l'AMA a été créée à l'origine
c'estdire que des gens qui font le
boulot aussi sur le terrain or il ne le
font pas ils peuvent pas le faire donc
parmi les recommandations de Lama il y
avait il y a parfois des des choses
toutes bêtes comme le le le véhicule
antidopage doit être au plus près il
était une fois trop loin il doit être
sur la ligne et cetera il y a eu aussi
les chaperons c'est comment direce qui
n'existait pas autrefois c'estd que il y
a désormais dans toutes les épreuves
mais ça a été le cas peut-être avant les
autes sur le Tour de France euh h
chaperon qui donc vont récupérer tous
les soirs restent en permanence avec le
coureur qui va être contrôlé et cetera
le suivent la première année c'était
plus ou moins de briqu et de broc avec
des gens qui nous étaient recommandés
par la Fédération Française et cetera
c'est de puis
euh une une
entreprise des Pyrénées Atlantiques dont
le nom m'échappe à l'instant qui nous
avait été recommandé je crois d'ailleurs
par la FLD à l'époque qui travaill aussi
sur Rand Garos et et ces gens-l sont là
c'était une des recommandations de
là-bas une obligation du code mondial
page ça n'existait pas autrefois ça
existe ça existe
aujourd'hui après le rapport de Lama euh
bah tout ça il fait après c'est qu' il y
a un moment où ce serait aussi
formidable de de de de de pouvoir
changer les choses si on sait quelque
chose la deuxième étape c'est peut-être
pas mal de le changer tout de
suite alors Lab précisément dans dans
son rapport 2010 avait pointé du doigt
en quelque sorte le le caractère trop
prévisible des contrôle mené sur sur
l'épreuve est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec cette affirmation est-ce que vous
êtes associé à la mise en place de de
ces contrôle bon je crois qu'au début
c'était quatre contrôles le le vainqueur
de l'étape le maillot jaune et puis a
deux tirages au sort après on est passé
à 6 à la demande de l'UCI est-ce que
vous êtes associé à cette à ce à ces
choix à C cette logistique non nous ce
que nous avons pu dire notamment après
2008 et la FLD c'est on veut rester au
même niveau de contrôle sachant que
c'est l'organisateur qui les paye donc
j'ai les chiffres dans les yeux hein
c'est 548 en 2008 555 en 2009 c'est
monté à 634 en 2010 c'est un peu moins
maintenant 566 en 2012 mais avec une
augmentation des contrôles sanguins ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure donc
on n'est pas associé à on'est pas
associé à ça il y a y a il y a une il y
a une réunion classique et annuelle à la
FLD avec la FLD avec l'UCI et avec nous
où on dit bah voilà vous aurez combien
d'inspecteurs et cetera parce qu'après
on doit aussi organiser la logistique ce
qui est un détail mais qui n'en est pas
un dans le Tour de France c'estàdire que
euh il y a je vous le disais tout à
l'heure deux fois trois équipes de
Médecins de fois trois équipes de
d'agents des contrôles donc il faut
voilà savoir quand ils arrivent et
cetera mettre les voitures les pilles
les chauffeurs les les les hôtels donc
on est associé à cette partie-là et
ensuite sur le fait de on en veut
tempant nous nous avons insisté depuis
enfin en tout cas moi depuis que je suis
là non seulement sur le Tour mais sur
les contrôles qui ont lieu avant non pas
pour faire en sorte que les coureurs qui
trichent soi pris pendant le Tour mais
pour que ceux qui trichent et dont on
sait qu'il trichent soi pris quand ils
trichent et et on a une vraie difficulté
là-dessus notamment euh je suis de lire
les journaux pour se dire est-ce vrai ou
pas mais en tout cas quand on est à ma
place de directeur on se dit attends si
on nous explique il sont en train de se
charger au mois de mai ou en juin on
étant dans les stages faudrait peut-être
aller voir euh s'occuper d'eux à ce
moment-là plutôt que d'attendre qu'il
soit départ du Tour de France et qu'on
ne puisse plus rien faire donc cet
aspect là de ciblage dans les semaines
qui précèdent c'est le mois de mai c'est
la fin avril fin avril début juin on a
qu'une envie c'est que ça se fasse il
est arrivé qu'on demande des contrôles
qu'on finance les contrôles et que un
diè des contrôles qu'on est demandé soit
faitoujours toujours dans ce même
rapport donc de l'Agence mondiale
antidopage il était noté je cite je suis
précis je vous en prie que beaucoup de
gens sur le Tour même ceux impliqués
dans la lutte contre le dopage ont
parfois un attachement malsin avec les
compétiteurs que ce soit par des amitiés
personnelles ou seulement pour avoir été
présent depuis plusieurs années sur le
Tour donc il y a une sorte de de
proximité affective qui se crée ça fait
aussi partie de l'intérêt du Tour de
France d'ailleurs ce côté familial
populaire festif récréatif et cetera
mais est-ce que justement cette ambiance
là cet état d'esprit là n'est pas
devenue au fil du temps
une sorte d'entrave à la lutte antiopage
donc comment assurer véritablement
l'indépendance du contrôle dans dans
dans ces conditions et et à vos yeux une
question collatérale une question annexe
est-ce que d'après vous l'UCI notamment
fait tout pour que les les contrôleurs
préleveurs agissent de manière
totalement indépendant totalementome
autonome sans difficulté aucune sur sur
les arrivées d'étapes
notamment sur le lien avec les champions
euh je crois que les chaperons sont un
vrai pas en avant quand quand j'évoquais
tout à l'heure que la première année
c'était des gens recommandé par la
Fédération française par exemple donc
des gens qui sont dans le monde du véo
il y a eu un vrai changement qui a même
parfois surpris parce que ça pouvait
être raide en revanche il y a des
médecins qui sont sur le Tour depuis ces
dernières années bah ils prennent des
photos des champions comme le faisaient
les médecins d'avant quoi et et et
faut-il leur reprocher à un moment
c'estd que c'est pas parce que les gens
sont là depuis 10 ans alors il peut
jeement peut se créer mais mais il y a
la fascination qui existe dès le départ
le le champion fascine qu'on aime ou
qu'on aime pas le champion fascine et
fascinera toujours après est-il un
exemple c'est un are problème faut-il
d'ailleurs qu'il soit un exemple c'est
pas la question d'aujourd'hui mais mais
il fascinera toujours le champion donc
les gens oui mais parfois c'est la
première fois qu'il les voi physiquement
mais ils les ont vu et que vous soyez
médecin chaperon directeur sportif
journaliste organisateur du Tour c'est
la même
chose j'ai j'ai vu des médecins
oui prendre des photos oui
bien sûr et applaudir les coururs qui
passent oui mais est-ce que c'est
mal il y avit une deuxième partie pardon
monsieur le sénateur mais je je sais
plus ce que
c'est c'était sur l'indépendance des des
préurs je peux je ne peux que vous
redire que nous ne souhaitons qu'une
seule chose c'est que ce soit un
organisme totalement indépendant qui
gère tout
l'antidopage pour tous les sports et
pour tous les pays avec les mêmes règles
partout et pour tout le monde autement
il y aura pas de solution
concernant les les équipes le contrôle
que
vous effectuez sur les équipes je me
suis laissé dire c'est peut-être une
fausse information qu'il y avait des
enquêteurs privés pour contrôleres
équipes est-ce que c'est uniquement le
fruit de l'imagination d'un certain
nombre de personnes ou est-ce que c'est
une réalité dans l'hypothèse où ces
enquêteurs privés existeraient ont-ils
la possibilité ou souhait-il ont-ils des
instructions pour coopérer avec la
police avec la douane et cetera et
cetera et deuxièmement concernant la
douane puisque je viens d'en parler nous
avons reçu un responsable de la douane
et qui nous a expliqué
que suite à l'affaire
Festina les douanes auraient reçu
instruction auraiit reçu instruction de
limiter leurs investigations sur le Tour
de France qu'en est-il cela vous
semble-t-il plausible je vous laisse
évidemment répondre alors sur sur les
douanes je ne suis que le directeur du
cyclisme d'amor et Sport Organisation
entreprise de 220 salariés qui
organisent un géant le Tour de France je
n'ai pas la main sur les douanes ce que
je peux simplement vous dire c'est
qu'ils sont venus en 2008 les douanes
sont venus en 2008 c'est pas ce qui a
été dit chez vous les douanes sont venus
sur le Tour de France 2008 d'ailleurs
c'était dans toutes les gazettes puisque
ils ont voulu intercepter en pleine
étape Johnny Schlek le père de frankck
et son prénom m'échappe Andy Schlek et
que ça s'est
fait dans le cours de l'étape et que
c'était dans tous les journaux
absolument partout et il n rien trouvver
dans sa voiture j'imagine que s'ils ont
fait ça sils avent une bonne raison de
le faire mais je vous confirme qu'ils
étaient bien là en
2008 fameuse entre guillemets ah les
enquêteurs privés alors oui je
j'entendais ce que ce que ce qui a été
dit Pierre brandri vous interrogeait
tout
en félicit l'organisation du Tour pour
sa lutte contre le dopage disait mais en
fait ils en savent plus qu'ils veulent
bien le dire et en parlant de va et
viens à la frontière espagnole et en
dors en 2009 et que les organisateurs
auraient dit d'ailleurs à une réunion
ensuite convoquant les managers faut pas
faire ça parinis j'avais une interview
ce matin pour un journaliste qui
travaille pour pièce à conviction sur la
3 qui m'a posé cette question aussi euh
nous avons des rendez-vous réguliers
avec les équipes à la veille de parénis
en tout cas depuis que je suis arrivé
comme juin 2004 et sans doute depuis des
années avant il y a une réunion où on
convoque tous les managers et directeurs
sportifs et où et on leur explique voilà
la saison c'est ça Paris c'est demain ça
se passe comme ça Paris rou c'est ça il
y a un changement de parcours le Tour de
France attention vos hôtels seront à tel
endroit sans qu'ils sachent dans quels
hôtels ils seront mais en revanche on
leur dit ben voilà il y a un hôtel qui
est à 5 km un hôtel qui est à 10 km pour
qu'ils puissent anticiper sur la la
logistique nécessaire donc ça c'est
quelque chose de régulier
euh c'est pas une fois c'est c'est pas
deux fois c'est pas trois fois que dans
des réunions comme celle-là comme lors
du briefing général d'avantour qui se
déroulait avant le vendredi qui se
déroule maintenant le jeudi qui précède
le tour comme à chacune des rencontres
avec les directeurs sportifs puisquil y
en a une la veille de chaque course à
17h il y a eu samedi à compienne à 17h
il y aura mardi prochain à Binche dép de
la flèche en Belgique à 17h il y aura
samedi à Liège de la semaine prochaine à
17h si je n'ai pas fait une fois deux
fois 10 fois 50 fois le sermon du père
fouatard en leur disant arrêtez je ne
l'ai jamais fait alors on me parle de
j'entends parler d'un d'un film où on
aurait montré des voitures passant la
frontière j'avais un mail la semaine
dernière d'un d'un un nom anglais
anglophone en tout cas de consonance
anglaise me disant alors les
hélicoptères qui circulent la nuit la
semaine prochaine sont des sous-marins
c'est on nous on nous parle de quoi en
revanche en revanche j'ai évoqué j'ai
évoqué lors d'une de ces dernières
réunions d'une de ces réunionsl 2010
peut-être je me souviens plus peut-être
2010 quelque chose qui s'était c passé
pend le jour 2007 et en 2007 on avait su
après coup que les enquêteurs de l'ES
avaent tenté de filer une voiture
d'Astana qui était parti à 1h du matin
naturellement à 1h du matin ils ont
quelque chose à faire c'était évident et
qui n'avait pas réussi à les suivre et
c'est ça que je leur ai dit je leur ai
dit ça maintenant je serais curieux de
savoir comment ça s'est transformé enfin
ça fait partie du du royaume de la
rumeur ça c'est clair mais en revanche
oui je ser je serais je serais
irresponsable je n'aimerais pas Tour de
France si en chaque occasion je ne
disais pas au manager directeur sportif
arrêtez je prends souvent des
précautions en disant je sais que je
m'adresse à certains d'entre vous qui ne
trichent pas je sais que d'autres ont
changé et je crains hélas que certains
n'ai pas compris je l'ai fait la semaine
dernière samedi dernier
encore et juste avant que tu ne avant
que le rapporteur ne reprenne Dominique
B avait demandé la parole je la lui
donne merci Président Monsieur le
Directeur général lors de d'audition on
nous a aussi fait part de difficultés
pour les préleveurs
d'accéder au au coureurs et bien
évidemment si c'est 15 20 minutes on
sait très bien ce qui peut se passer et
la fiabilité des contrôles sont altérés
alors vous en êtes bien évidemment au
courant comment on peut améliorer cette
situation parce que on nous explique
certaines équipes ont des services de
sécurité donc c'est compliqué par
rapport justement à à ce que vous avez
évoqué sur
d'améliorer les relation entre les
équipes les managers et l'organisateur
est-ce que ça on pourrait pas en faire
un point dur de discussion vous vous
êtes inscrit autour mais vous devez
permettre au préleveur d'accéder au
coureur beaucoup plus rapidement parce
que ça c'est tout le monde est au
courant de ce fait est-ce que vous avez
des des pistes de réflexion et d'action
là certainement moi je crois sur t qu'il
faut pouvoir contrôler pendant les
stages parce que la photographie qui est
faite de laaffaire hamsong c'est une
photographie du passé c'est pas le
cycliste d'aujourd'hui qui n'est pas un
monde parfait c'est quand même plus
pareil et notamment par le passeport
c'est qu'il y a tellement de
contrôle il y a tellement de contrôle
qu'on peut guerre en en faire plus ou ou
ou faire mieux en revanche pouvoir
empêcher les gens de se préparer en mai
ou en juin ça me paraît quelque chose
d'absolument capital plus que qu'autre
chose parce que peut-être que dans les
textes de l'UCI il est possible de
rajouter des choses mais comment ça se
passe ça se passe à 6h du matin dans un
hôtel le gars arrive il dort bien
légitimement faut bien voir les choses
aussi c'est que si on sort de l'aspect
laadopage j'entendais dire on ne peut
contrôler que 7h du mat ou 6h du mat à
21h mais d'une certaine manière
heureusement
heureusement certains coureurs moi me
disent mais qu'on nous mette un bracelet
on sera plus
tranquille ça n'a quand même pas de
sens donc moi je je je suis vraiment
convaincu que que
dans les stages le moment où ceux qui
trichent encore se préparent c'est à ce
moment-là qu'il faut essayer de les
prendre et évidemment le fait que outre
l'UCI l'Agence française de lu dopage
puisse récupérer la localisation pas
simplement des Français mais tout le
monde est est une donnée
essentiel merci Michel Savin puis
ensuite Dominique
bioné tout l'URE
a est- que que comment vous pensez qu'un
manager aujourhui
savoir est-ce que vous pensez qu'un
manager
aujourd'hui peut ne pas savoir qu'un de
ces coureurs se de parce que lorsqu'on
entend la presse et autres qu'un joueur
se fait attraper on on a l'impression
que tout le monde découvre que ce
coureur se et et et c'est pour aller
plus loin aujourd'hui un coureur se fait
attraper les sanctionné suspendu le
manager passe au travers oui donc est-ce
qu'il y a pas possibilité de sauf si
vous vous m'expliquez qu'on nous
explique que le manager ne peut pas
savoir que que son coureur se dope mais
à ce compte là soit dans le contrat de
travail soit au niveau de de la
réglementation sanctionner aussi
fortement le manager parce
que si on veut aussi alors j'entends
bien les contrôles bien en amont des
compétitions mais au moment de la
sanction il faut aussi que ceux qui sont
qui cautionnent ou qui protège ou qui
organise ce type de comportement soit
aussi sanctionné ce sont les règles que
s'impose d'ors et déjà le mouvement pour
un cyclisme crédible un manageur peut ne
pas savoir qu'un courur triche mais sur
la durée c'est évidemment
impossible le mouvement pour un cyclisme
crédible m en place un système qui
autosanctionne l'équipe à partir d'un
certain nombre de contrôle seul Cofidis
dans le passé l'a fait je vais vous dire
des bêtises mais vous trouverez ça très
facilement je crois qu'au deuxième
contrôle c'est c'est en 18 mois c'est
c'est 8 jours d'arrêt ensuite c'est un
mois d'arrêt et cetera et cetera donc là
l'équipe n'est pas au départ donc ça
change tout ça change tout pour eux ça
change tout pour ceux qui n'ont pas
triché dans l'équipe qui se disent mais
attends mais tu es gentil mon coco mais
il faut pas recommencer et évidemment
pour le partenaire pour le sponsor pour
le partenaire privé si cette règle là
était une règle non pas enfin non pas un
choix volontaire de certaines équipes
mais une obligation ça changera des
choses
évidemment utilisez votre micro mon
chers collègue parce que ce type
d'exemple qui est aujourd'hui limité à
une
équipe pas pas une équipe elles sont
enfin c'est la moitié des équipes du
Tour mais c'est ils sont plus d'une
trentaine maintenant mais ils étaient
h ok donc ayant fait ayant dit c'est la
voie suivre au mois d'octobre un
certainom d'équipes et notamment toutes
les équipes de 2e division ont dit on va
y aller mais aussi parce qu'ils savent
très bien en 2è division sil veulentêre
pris sur No cours s son s'ils sont pas
dedans ils seront ils seront pas au
départ donc je suis pas totalement fou
il y a des conversions récentes dont on
peut se méfier mais mais mais en
revanche ce système du MPCC ben oui il
serait formidable qu'il soit appliqué
partout alors la réponse qui est faite
régulièrement c'est c'est un problème
juridique vous n'avez pas le droit de
vous ne pouvez pas ça nexction du
volontariat bien sûr que ça changera
énormément les
choses merci monsieur le rapporteur
oui
sur les observations formulées par l'AMA
il y a aussi des aspects positifs si je
peux dire notamment concernant l'azo et
vous félicitant pour votre contribution
au
financement des contrôle donc je voudis
savoir où vous en êtes aujourd'hui
combien chaque année vous consacrez au
financement de ce type de de contrôle
sur l'ensemble de la saison à peu près
700000 € en tenant compte des des des
analyses et et de la mise à disposition
des voitures et cetera de l'hébergement
de DESP puisqueon on prend les
l'organisateur doit totalement prendre
en charge il s'occuper de la gare ou de
l'aéroport le moment où ils arrivent
jusque après la course les remettre à
l'aéroport environ 700000
€ dans la continuité de de
l'interpellation de de notre collègue
Dominique bailli je reviens un instant
sur tout le système Armstrong parce que
bon
on voit maintenant que les produits
utilisés n'avaient absolument rien de
nouveau rien de de révolutionnaire mais
que par contre il a bénéficié de tout un
système de de protection tout un système
de de complicité qu'il a bénéficié d'une
sorte de traitement de
faveur type hélicoptère qui attendait à
l'arrivée de de l'étape semble-t-il une
protection physique rapproché que
n'avait pas les les autres
coureurs comment expliquez-vous je
dirais cette cette situation et et là je
pose le problème tout simplement en
terme de d'équité sportive parce que
semble-t-il il bénéficie d'un traitement
tout à fait spécifique non il y a pas
d'hélicoptère dans l'excellente
intervention de Jean-Pierre de Menard il
a dit à un moment effectivement Henri
Desgrange n'aurais jamais fait ça Félix
lvitant Félix LV je ne sais pas mais
Henri Desgrange avec un hélicoptère pour
aller chercher le vainqueur à l'étape
effectivement ça aurait été
compliqué simplement vous dire que un
hélicoptère est mis à
disposition pour les cours qui sont
retardés à l'arrivée de l'étape soit
parce qu'ils sont sur le podium soit
parce qu'ils passent au contrôle
antidopage évidemment 7 tours aant volé
se
tour étant maillot jaune ou étant
vainqueur d'étape il avait droit à ça
c'est pas parce que CIT monsieurson qui
avait son hélicoptère c'est parce que
c'est parce que c'est le maillot jaune
le vainqueur tous ceux qui sont retenus
par le protocole ou par le
contrôle en revanche nous avons mis des
hélicoptères à dispos
position sur le dernier tour de
France après l'ENT e étape avant le
contre la montre finale et là on a pris
c'était ma décision je me suis fait
enguler et cetera mais on pouvait pas
faire autrement les 20 premiers du
classement général et on s'était demandé
est-ce qu'on en prend deux par équipe et
cetera j'ai tranché en disant je préfère
que ce soit les 20 priers donc le 21e le
22e le 23e le 25e on rallé c'était comme
ça mais c'est un c'est un cas
d'espèces ce qui est classique c'est
ceux qui sont retenus soit pour le
protocole soit pour l'antidopage d'un
quand vous êtes en en montagne et
certains d'entre vous viennent de la
montagne ben s'ils ne peuvent pas
prendre l'évacuation faite par la garde
républicaine et les gendarmes
départementaux ils sont bloqués pendant
4 heures donc le seul moyen pour
descendre c'est qu'ils sonit en
hélicoptère et ils peuvent pas être dans
ils peuvent pas être dans l'évacuation
s'ils sont s'ils sont ils sont retardés
par un contrôle parce qu'ils ont des
interview ils sont salle de
presse donc vous n'avez pas eu je je
reviens vous n'avez pas eu je dirais
de connaissance de de difficultés
qu'auraiit eu des des préleveurs dans
leurs conditions d'accès à Armstrong B
si je l'ai lu et entendu bien sûr
monsieur Bordry m'avait appelé
d'ailleurs en 2009 pour pour me dire qu'
Andor ça c'était mal passé non en 2009
si peut-être parce que la f était encore
dans le coup je me trompe peut-être en
tout cas je me souviens que j'is eu un
coup de téléphone pour dire ça s'est pas
bien passé 200 en revche qui a été
évoqué sur le Ventou 2009 j'ai découvert
avec vous c'estàd que dire que il avait
pas pu être contrôlé il y avait une
demande pour qu'amstrong soit contrôlé
mais qu'il était trop loin la veille
qu'il avait déjà été contrôlé 24 heur
avant et que apparemment les les les
gens qui voulaient contrôler les
inspecteurs de l'ci sans doute ont dit
non mais il faut pas le faire ça je
savais pas du tout en Revan j'ai bien
vérifié la distance de l'hôtel
d'Armstrong je me suis replongé dans le
livre de route de l'époque il était logé
dans un
hôtel au sud de de de montimar et
effectivement pour remonter jusqu'au
départ l'étape suivante en tenant compte
de ce qu'on appelle nous le PPO que les
les les élus qui accueillent
régulièrement le Tour de France
connaissent le point de passage obligé
qui fait qu'à un moment on dit faut
passer par là si vous voulez arriver
dans le bon sens au départ de l'étape du
Tour de France et effectivement on était
à 70 km ce qui était annoncé lors de
l'intervention en
question merci Alan Erie oui très
rapidement Monsieur le Directeur si j'ai
bien compris votre expli votre vos
explications qui sont très intéressantes
et on n'en doutez pas par votre
connaissance du sujet il me semble que
on est au moins d'accord sur un point
c'est que ce qui nous intéresse c'est
l'efficacité de la lutte contre le
dopage et à la limite vous nous dites si
j'ai bien compris vous me direz le
contraire si je me
trompe les contrôles à l'arrivée et
pendant l'épreuve faut les maintenir
mais l'efficacité du contrôle c'est les
contrôles inopinés avant les épreuves
dans dans le cas de la préparation à des
stages et donc ça rejoint ma
préoccupation de se d'appuyer très
fortement également de la condamnation
des
aut parce que je crois que l'aut et le
contrôle inopiné si on supprime les aut
et si on renforce le contrôle inopiné
mon sentiment c'est que le contrôle sera
beaucoup plus efficace et la lutte contô
le dopage plus efficace parce que les
préparation d'opage sont plus même qu'à
20 ansent je crois aussi le ciblage est
absolument essentiel pendant l'épreuvees
ça c'est certain je pense pas qu'une
augmentation du nombre de contrôle
puisse changer grand-chose en revanche
le ciblage est nécessaire et la capacité
à
aller même faire peur faire de la
dissuasion dire voilà les inspecteurs
vont venir quand vous êtes en sage à tel
endroit c'éta quelque chose d'absolument
essentiel et ça veut dire donc oui que
la FLD doit obtenir la localisation des
champions on peut pas
faire on ne peut pas créer la difficulté
c'est qu'on crée des choses à deux
vitesses entre entre les Français et les
autres et ça pas de sens moi je reviens
sur la médecine de santé j'en reviens
parce que parce que rien n' bougé depuis
des années que des médecins d'équipe
françaises me disent ça depuis longtemps
la médecine de santé doit aussi être un
argument non pas pour dire vous trichez
monsieur mais on est désolé vu votre
état physique ferez pas le
T Stéphane Mazard
oui merci monsieur le Président
euh la lutte contre le dopage repose
essentiellement sur le contrôle
principalement est-ce que selon vous il
faut d'autres moyens d'investigation
pour confondre donc les tricheurs voilà
le le le le rôle de la gendarmerie de la
police et des douanes sont sont
évidemment essentiels pendant des années
et des années les affaires ne sont
arriver que comme ça euh mais ils
doivent encore être là si luusada ne ne
s'acharne pas il y a rien et et et
dernière question
euh aujourd'hui donc le le le sportif
confondu il est sanctionné sportivement
il fait pas l'objet de poursuite pénale
est-ce qu'il faut aller plus loin dans
la sanction dans la la poursuite d'abord
et dans la sanction du du sportif selon
vous est-ce que ça peut avoir un effet
dissuasif vous en avez parlé tout à
l'heure parce qu'effectivement on sait
que les sanctions sportives c'est très
lourd pour pour pour le sportif qui
s'est qui a souvent sacrifié beaucoup de
choses pour son sport et qui se retrouve
pendant 2 ans 3 ans donc à devoir rester
à la
maison mais c'est vrai qu'en
contrepartie de la tricherie ben il a eu
la gloire il a eu parfois l'argent
est-ce qu'il faut aller plus loin encore
une fois sur sur la sanction
je crois que la sanction pour l'
essentiel doit rester sportive en
revanche la norme pour certains produits
d lourd comme le PO si elle passait de 2
à 4 ans ça changerait des choses pour
l'instant c'est 2 ans avec parfois des
des
des des
sanctions rétroactive c'est que je
prends le 4 comptador il était pas
question de P je prend
comptador ça a quand même traîné 18 mois
la Fédération espagnole ne le conit
quasiment pas l'UCI dit on veut pas de
ça fin conit plus mais pendant temps il
a cour
gag Tour d'Italie fait 5è du
Tour et tout ça B c'est rayé et puis
après on vous dit il est suspendu 2 ans
mais en fait est suspendu de janvier ça
fait que 6 mois parce qu'il est déjà
suspendu depuis 2 ans puon a tout rayé
vous vous rendez compte pour les
organisateurs ce que ça veut dire parce
qu' obligé de le
prendre il obligé de le prendre le je
par pour Leo il a gagné il devait le
prendre au départ pvez pas lui dire vous
n'êtes pas là et après non ils ont ré
était pas là en
fait et il y a un décalage le monde
médiatique fait qu'on va de plus en plus
vite sur tout il y a un décalage
invraisemblable il faut sûrement pas
aller à la vitesse du monde médiatique
ce serait de la folie furieuse bien
au-delà du monde du sport ce serait fou
mais en revanche il y a un décalage
total entre entre le temps de la justice
peut-être en général mais en
l'occurrence la sportive et et et et ce
qu'on demande aux gens et dans le monde
du sport comme les coureurs peuvent-être
les athlètes peuvent être au départ tant
qu'ils sont pas sanctionnés ils sont là
quoi si si si euh si en attendant la
sanction il ne pouvait pas courir
c'était établi définitivement ça
changerait des
choses merci on revient vers le
rapporteur je vous signale mes chers
collègues le temps avance donc
oui Monsieur le Directeur il y a eu une
une période où les relations étaient
quand même assez tendues entre ao et et
l'UCI en particulier la période
2005-2008 euh comment expliquer euh le
changement d'attitude donc à partir de
de 2008 comment les choses se sont
passer est-ce que quelqu'un comme
Jean-Claude kilily par exemple a joué un
rôle essentiel comme médiateur comme on
a pu le voir ici ou
là comment on est sorti de cette
situation un peu difficile je je vous
l'ai dit il y a une décision politique
du groupe de dire il faut arrêter de
faire la guerre je n'étais
personnellement dans aucune des
discussions qui ont pu avoir
lieu je voudrais voir votre votre
sentiment sur une proposition qui est
faite parfois dans la période récente
c'est sur le retour à des équipes
nationale sur le Tour de France avec
puisqu'on parle de dopage en particulier
la mise en place d'un d'un pool de
médecins une équipe de médecins qui
serait la disposition de l'ensemble des
coureurs que l'Allemagne de l'Est était
belle
euh c'est pas ça qui va faire qu'on va
lutter contre le dopage ou pas ça n ça
n'a rien à voir pour moi je pense que
dans le l'organisation du monde du
cyclisme aujourd'hui les partenaires qui
viennent euh sur le sport cycliste si
vous leur dites euh bah vous faites tout
SAF le Tour de France
h pas certain que que ça les intéresse
euh c'est une formidable idée mais je je
je je crois qu'elle n'est plus de son
temps je crois davantage au aux aux
équipes soutenues par une région pour
qu'il y ait des racines euh même si la
fameuse équipe basquecaltel escad a pris
exactement le chemin inverse l'hiver
dernier euh en accueillant dans son sein
des coururs de toute nationalité alors
qu' se réserv av autrefis que des
Basques faut peut-être pas aussi dur que
ça mais qui a une appartenance qui a une
identité me paraît essentielle dans un
sport comme le cyclisme qui est un sport
où les champions vont vers les gens
c'est pour ça qu'il est populaire
c'est-à-dire que j'avais souhaité moi
avant le départ de de Jean-Marie Leblanc
il y a une demi-douzaine d'années faire
une réunion sur le thème le tour de mes
rêves et et la plus belle réponse que
j'ai entendu de la part d'un de mes
collaborateurs dont le fils s'appelle
Augustin je me méfie parce que Augustin
est devenu mon fils alors que ma fille
s'appelle Marion j'ai une fille unique
elle s'appelle Marion et j'ai raconté
cette qui soit là un jour et Augustin
est devenu mon fils donc non c'est le
fils d'un de mes collaborateurs qui
s'appelle Augustin et et qui a dit papa
le tour de mes rêves c'est le tour qui
passe chez moi c'est la plus belle
réponse qu'on puisse entendre il n'a pas
demandé le tourmalis le Galibier les
pavés le tour qui passe chez moi et ce
lien là il existe parce que les les
champions les coururs vont chez vous ils
passent sur le pas de la porte le tour
ce sont trois piliers c'est bien sûr le
sport et il faut lutter pour que ce
sport redevienne crédible c'est
l'esthétique ce sont les paysages c'est
la mise en valeur des territoires les
terroirs et c'est le lien le Tour de
France est une épreuve qui faitdère vous
avez des gens de tout de toute
conditions au bord de la route vous avez
des gens de toute nationalité vous avez
les anciens devant les maisons de
retraite et les gamas devant les
centresar les colonies c'est ça le Tour
de France c'est ce qu'il faut défendre
mais on peut pas défendre le Tour de
France seul on ne peut y aller
qu'ensemble et c'est aussi pour ça qu'à
un moment il y a eu la fin de la guerre
c'estàd que si vous êtes seul vous
n'avez aucune chance de vous en sortir
ce n'est pas possible ce n'est pas
possible est-ce que vous avez par
rapport à cette problématique mais
également d'autres des relations des
rencontres régulières suivies avec les
organisateurs des autres grands tours
girud Velta alors nous nous nous av je
je suis le le le président de ce qui
s'appelle l'ayoc association
internationale des orordanisateurs de
cours cyclistes aioo de C euh donc nous
avons des réunions euh euh trois fois
par an euh comité directeur puis une
assemblée générale et cetera où où
chacun fait part de de ses difficultés
les les difficultés qui peuvent remonter
elles sont d'abord économiques euh vous
avez des courses qui tombent en Espagne
quasiment tous les jours vous avez des
courses qui disparaissent un peu partout
d'autres qui naissent d'ailleurs mais il
y a aussi ce ce ce que je vous dis sur
la nécessité d'avoir un organisme
indépendant qui gère le dopage c'est
clairement remonté de tous les
organisateurs de l'association un
organisme
indépendant qui gère pour toutes les
disciplines et dans tous les pays ça ça
remonte pas simplement du Tour ça
remonte pas simplement de moi ça remonte
de tous les
organisateurs parmi les derniers sujets
que nous souhaitons
évoquer on reste dans le cadre du Tour
de France et des courses cyclistes
organisées par ao et on s'interroger sur
les rapports entre ASO et luci vous avez
commencé à répondre à donner un certain
nombre d'éléments
d'information on avait eu le sentiment
que les rapports entre les deux
partenaires ASO et UCI était assez
conflictuel dans dans la période 2005 à
2008 et il semblerait que les chose se
soit quelque peu amélioré est-ce que
c'est seulement une impression ou est-ce
que c'est une réalité et dans le cas où
ce sera une réalité comment peut-on
expliquer ce changement qui s'est
produit c'est une question simple mais
on aimerait vous entendre sur ce sujet
il y a eu assurément une période de
guerre he pendant les 4 années après le
après l'annonce du calendrier ProTour
par l'UCI mais c'était pas simplement ça
le combat il était aussi sur
l'éthique et ensuite il y a eu une
décision encore une fois politique du
groupe de dire on ne s'en sortira pas si
la guerre continue et c'est une décision
que j'ai parfaitement comprise et que
j'assume totalement et je vous le répète
à ce moment-là il y a eu aussi l'arrivée
du passeport biologique donc les
relations se sont normalisées j'ai
intégré moi le conseil du cycliste
professionnel qui se déroule trois fois
par an et où je suis l'un des deux
représentants des organisateurs il y a
12 membres plus lu C
euh Commission dans laquelle j'aurais dû
siéger dès 2005 avec le directeur du
Tour d'Italie mais nous avions été
boutés hors de l'instance parce qu'il y
avait conflit euh donc je fais partie de
de cette instance qui se réunit encore
une trois fois par an c'est cette
instance là qui a voté par exemple le
fait que les managers que les
coureurs étant condamnés pour page pour
plus de 6 mois ne puisse plus être
derrière membre à aucune place que ce
soit d'une équipe sportive sauf que en
l'occurrence malheureusement on s'est
heurté à une barrière juridique pour ne
pas revenir en arrière mais c'est à
partir du 1er janvier 2011 donc il y a
des relation que je vais vous qualifier
de normaliser moi je vois maed trois
fois enfin trou bien sûr le tour parfois
mais en tout cas dans ces trois réunions
là avec ce conseil du CIS professionnel
don je suis l'un des 12 membres
oui dernière question monsieur le
directeur après le contenu du rapport de
de l'usada est-ce
que vous pensez que que l'UCI n'a pas un
problème de crédibilité dans la lutte
contre le
dopage sur le passé
euh il y a naturellement un C N de
questions qui se posent pas vous dire le
contraire voir plus
euh je pense qu'avec le passeport ça a
vraiment évolué encore une fois c'est
pas un monde parfait mais je crois que
ça a changé sur ce qui s'est passé
autrefois j'ai les interrogations que
n'importe quel citoyen
a mes chers
collègues je fait le tour personne ne
demande plus la parole si vous avez
autre chose que vous auriez voulu
évoquer et que nous l'avons pas évoquer
nous-même non vous vous redire
simplement que c'est forcément une
bataille intern national
euh avancer seul dans son coin peut être
pire que tout parce qu'il y a pas de
solution derrière la médecine de santé
est assurément un axe est-ce possible
pas possible puisqueen fait on sort
toujours à des questions juridiques il
faut un organisme réellement indépendant
qui gère l'ensemble du sport mondial
toutes les disciplines et quel que soit
le pays et le l'entourage soi-disant
médecin ou docteur en médecine qui ne
sont en vérité pas médecin managers
parce que leur rôle est clé et que
certains sont encore une fois
formidables mais d'autres beaucoup moins
ce sont pour moi les éléments
essentiels merci au nom de cette
commission d'enquête des membres
aujourd'hui présent et même si certains
ont dû partir en cours d'audition j'ai
noté parce que je suis présent chacune
d'entre elles le nombre plus important
qu'il y avait de membres aujourd'hui
présents donc merci d'avoir répondu à
nos question question et merci à mes
collègues d'être venus je leur indique
qu'il y en a encore une qui ne partent
pas tout de suite s'il vous
plaît mes chers collègues
nous continuons
notre réunion d'aujourd'hui en
recevant Monsieur Bernard Laporte ancien
secrétaire d'État au
sport je voudrais préciser parce que
c'est ce que l'on doit faire dans une
commission d'enquête
que aucune manifestation positive ou
négative de la part de celles et ceux
qui assiste à nos travaux ne peut être
faite et que je vais dans un instant
monsieur le ministre vous demandez ce
qui est la règle dans les commissions
d'enquête de prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité en levant la main
droite en disant je
jure je jure de dire que la vérité merci
nous
sommes en réunion depuis
maintenant 3 semaines environ pour cette
commission
d'enquête relative à la lutte contre le
dopage mes collègues essaient
d'assister chaque fois qu'ils le peuvent
à nos réunions et nous avons eu depuis
le début de l'après-midi un nombre
fluctuant de part participant mais nous
sommes de 3 4 5 on il a plus de 6
personnes aujourd'hui pour commencer
notre travail
euh je vais vous laisser nous si vous le
souhaitez nous dire quelques mots
pendant 10 minutes un quart d'heure 20
minutes s'il le fallait sur l'objet de
cette rencontre et puis nous vous
poserons des
questions c'est la tradition en
particulier Jean-Jacques lozac
rapporteur de la commission d'enquête et
membre du groupe qui est à l'origine de
cette commission d'enquête lui-même et
son groupe et puis mes collègues ici
présents pourront à leur tour vous poser
toutes les questions qu'ils ont envie de
poser donc monsieur le ministre nous
vous
écoutons merci monsieur le Président
d'abord bonjour à toutes et et à
tous vous dire merci de m'avoir convié à
cette commission d'enquête parce que le
dopage Ctait quelque chose de très
important dans le sport pour avoir été
au ministère des Sports j'ai continuer
l'action entreprise euh par
euh madame buffet bien relayé ensuite
par ses par ses successeurs et et je
dois dire quand je suis arrivé quand
j'allais au notamment au aux réunions de
Lama la France était regarder avec
beaucoup de de sérieux parce que les
gens sentaient que c'était un un des un
des pays les mieux
organisés les plus forts je dirais dans
la lutte contre le dopage tout au moins
les plus engagés donc ça c'était
toujours avec une certaine fierté avec
un certain plaisir que qu'on côtoyait
tous nos amis du monde
entier et qu'il faut le rester leader de
la lutte contre le dopage on a eu
malheureusement quelques quelques débirs
pour pour ma part c'était durant le Tour
où la FLD qui avait fait un très très
bon travail puisqu'elle avait été convié
à être l'organisme qui gérait la lutte
contre leopage durant le Tour de France
a été écarté en 2009 au profit à nouveau
je dirais de de de de de lama et je dois
vous dire que ça a été un moment assez
douloureux pourquoi parce que ça c'était
tellement bien passé avec la FLD mais la
FLD n'était sous aucun ordre je dirais
la FLD elle était indépendante j'ai pas
senti la même chose quand Lama est
revenu et quand on regarde ce qui s'est
passé en 2008 tout a été clair entre
entre guillemets en 2009 sont revenus
certains problèmes donc je pense que
encore une fois il faut pas qu'on
qu'on qu'on arrête il faut qu'on soit
très appliqué très engagé dans cette
lutte contre contre le dopage et que
cette cet incident m'avait permis de
voir mais qu'il y avait des doutes
n'ayons pas peur de le dire sur certain
sur certaines choses pourquoi la FLD
n'avait pas été reconduite alors que
tout c'était bien passé ben tout
simplement parce que la Fédération
internationale de cyclisme avait perdu
le contrôle et qu'elle ne faisait plus
ce qu'elle ce qu'elle voulait faire elle
ne menait pas à la baaguette impression
la FLD comme elle pouvait le faire en en
mettant des gens à eux de la main donc
voilà donc continuons à être un pays
leader en terme de lutte contre le
dopage j'ai vu euh certaines certaines
déclarations
durant il y a quelques jours de cela de
de de de de la FLD où on mettait le
rugby comme le sport là aussi je crois
qu'il faut faire attention à ce que l'on
dit à l'information que l'on que l'on
diffuse parce que parce qu'elle peut
être négative pour notre sport alors
bien sûr que je vais défendre le le
sport qui est le mien rugby et et je je
vais le défendre et surtout pas le
mettre en exemple parce que on n'est pas
plus intelligent que les autres et qu'il
faut être vigilant là-dessus en terme de
lutte contre le dopage et que il est
clair que je ne connais pas un
entraîneur de club français de rugby qui
serait susceptible de de de de de
d'accepter qu'un joueur soit dopé tout
au moins au courant qu'un joueur de son
équipe soit dopé ça c'est impossible et
que le dopage collectif d'abord n'existe
pas parce que tôt ou tard bien sûr ça
vous retombe sur le coin du
euh ça ça Tom dessus puisque il y a
toujours un joueur qui le dirait donc ça
n'existe pas et que les diffusions qui
ont été qui ont été transmises il y a
quelques jours ben on fait de mon de mon
sport un sport attaqué coupable et et et
malheureusement c'est vrai qu'il avait
il y avait des copages mais quand on
regarde c'est souvent des cas de
cannabis donc il faudra qu'on m'explique
comment le cannabis peut être quand même
là aussi un produit dopan qui va
améliorer la performance en rugby et que
on a jeté le discrédit sur sur sur le
sport qui ne le méritait certainement
pas donc que tout le monde passe bien
son travail c'est une chose la diffusion
de l'information en est une autre il
faut faire à mon avis être vigilant
parce que ça peut jeter le discrédit sur
des choses qui n'en méritent qui ne le
mérite pas mais qu'encore une fois je ne
suis pas contre le travail réalisé par
FLD au contraire j'ai travaillé à leur
côté je sais ce dont il font et je les
encourage à continuer à être aussi
sérieux et aussi appliqué voilà après
j'ai pas grandchose à rajouter je suis
prêt bien sûr à répondre à toutes à
toutes vos questions on a eu nous aussi
vous savez par
exemple l'an dernier une de dopage sur
sur deux joueurs qui étaaient Stéphan
Hermitage et le pilier Lewis Roberts bon
quand on quand ça sort dans les journaux
Stéphan am
mitage pris pour dopage alors que quand
vous regardez quand vous attendez la
sanction il y a pas de sanction
puisqu'il a pas pris pour dopage il
avait pris des produits codéinés qui
sont autorisés dont la destruction de
ces produits
crée un substittu qui s'appelle je ne
sais pas je suis pas médecin qui
effectivement est dopan mais il il n'a
pas pris un produit dopan donc bien sûr
à la sortie c'est il y a rien il y a un
N lieu sauf que on a jeté le discrédit
là aussi sur des gens sur des personnes
alors qu'il ne le méritait pas donc je
crois que moi ce qui me gêne c'est que
tant que l'enquête n'est pas terminée
les choses sortent si le gars est pris
pour de pages il y a pas de problème on
le sort on a fait 10 pages c'est pas
c'est pas le souci et il le mérite mais
tant qu'on n' pas on n'a pas les
tenonant les aboutissants tant que le
joueur n'est pas condamné tant que le
joueur n'est pas sanctionné il faut
faire attention de de de de ne pas jeter
le discrédit parce que ça attaque les
familles ça attaque beaucoup de monde et
ça ça ça ça ça crée quand même chez les
joueurs des des
complications merci Monsieur le Ministre
s'il fallait vous rassurer mais il y a
pas besoin je vous diraiis simplement
que les membres de cette commission
d'enquête n'ont pas particulièrement mis
l'accent sur des pratiques qui auraient
pu exister dans un seul sport le vote en
l'occurrence il y a eu des déclarations
qui ont été rectifiées ensuite ou
précisé enite suite par la personne de
la FLD qui avait déclaré des choses et
on a tiré des conclusions un peu hatives
me semble-il sur la base d'une audition
tout à fait normale et vous verrez que
après votre passage devant nous et en
lisant la presse de demain je l'espère
nous n'aurons pas de mise au point
particulière à faire notre travail va
durer quelques mois encore nous sommes
conscients que ce n'est pas un sport
plus particulièrement qui est visé
nous avons une crainte parfois légitime
nous les commissaires membres de cette
commission d'enquête que beaucoup voire
la plupart voire la totalité des sports
sont concernés par ces problèmes de
dopage voilà on a tout dit mais c'est
l'occasion pour les représentants
éminents de chacun des sports de venir
nous dire ce qu'ils pensent de tout ça
surtout quand on a comme vous assumer
des responsabilités ministérielles lié à
ce problème sportif au sens générale du
terme si vous en êtes d'accord je vais
demander à Jean-Jacques loisac notre
rapporteur c'est un peu la manière dont
nous travaillons toujours de vous poser
quelques questions et puis les collègues
présents auront sans doute je vais
essayer de bien regarder qui demande la
parole pour leur passer ensuite la
parole merci oui merci Monsieur le
Ministre d'abord une question que l'on a
posé de manière récurrente euh à je
dirais parce que collègues c'est-à-dire
à à des personnes qui ont d'abord été
des sportifs de haut niveau avant de
devenir membre de tel ou tel
gouvernement en leur demandant si au
cours de leur parcours sportif de leur
itinéraire de pratiquant ils avaient eu
connaissance ou s'ils avaient été
confrontés à des situations de de dopage
en l'occurrence dans le dans le rugby
pour vous c'est une question qu'on a
posé à David Douillet Alain calma alors
je commence par vous la
poser non je n'ai personnellement pas
été confronté à ou à des partenaires ou
à des joueurs que j'entraînis qui qui se
dopaient tout
simplement mais mais quand on en parle
avec mes mes anciens partenaires
c'està-dire il y a quand même plus de 25
ans on prenait nous à l'époque des des
des des des des des cachets qui
s'appelaient captagon qui était interdit
mais bien sûr que N Savit pas que c
était
interdit le jour on nous a dit mais le
captagon fait partie des produits deop
bien sûr que tout le monde a arrêté mais
le captagon tout le monde
et je leur disais mais je sais pas si on
avait pris beaucoup ou pas assez mais
quand je revois les matchs c'est pas ce
qui nous a fait devenir meilleur
autrement non sincèrement pour être pour
être sérieux jamais jamais je l'ai
jamais
connu moi j'ai eu l'affaire de vill a
géré quand j'étais entraur d'équipe de
France bon euh on l'a
suspendu nous en équipe de France il n'a
jamais été suspendu par ailleurs bon on
s'est vite rendu compte qu'il il avait
il avait subi durant durant une soirée
nocturne ce qui arrivait à l'époque dans
certaines boîtes de Paris où on vous
mettait des des cachets dans le dans le
dans le verre qui fait que vous voilà
vous perdiez la mémoire la connaissance
et tout et puis vous saviez plus comment
vous étiez rentré c'est ce qui était
arrivé à pitur mais en aucun cas c'était
il n'avait il ne l'avait pris
volonirement et en aucune carte c'était
pour bien sûr pour améliorer sa
performance je le répète il n'a
d'ailleurs jamais été suspendu sauf par
nous puisqu'on avait dit nous ce qui
nous gêne c'est pas le caché c'est que
tu sois en boîte de nuit à 5h du matin
quoi voilà et qu'après il arrive quelque
chose quand on est un joueur de l'équipe
de France si à 5h du matin on est dans
une boîte de nuit mais il faut pas que
ça se sache voilà on a une valeur
d'exemple à respecter donc voilà
d'Autrement pour répondre à la question
jamais sincèrement je n'ai connu de
joueurs qui se qui se dopaient dans le
rugby que ce soit des partenaires ou que
ce soit des joueurs que j'ai que j'ai
entraîné
oui une une question sur l'organisation
globale he de la lutte antidopage en
France comment vous la la jugez la la
position du du ministère la position de
des fédérations sportives la position du
Comité olympique le laboratoire de Châ é
malabri la FLD cette c'est cette
architecture là quel quel regard vous
jetez dessus moi elle elle me elle me
dérange pas je la connaî bien sûr pour
avoir travaillé avec eux au ministère
elle me elle me dérange pas et et je me
rappelle qu'à l'époque on avait fait une
réunion là-dessus où il y avait tous les
tous les représentants de des divers
sports étaient là et c'est vrai que les
gens du cyclisme se plaignaient parce
quex ils avaient à répondre à à ce qu'on
appelle les les les joueurs enfit les
coureur cible où il devaient toute
l'année dire où où est-ce qu'ils étaient
ce qu'ils faisaient parce qu'ils étaient
susceptible d'être contrôl à tout moment
et cetera et cetera et eux avaient dit
pourquoi que le vélo et cetera et on
avait justement fait en sorte que tous
les sports
soient loger à la même enseigne et
qu'aujourd'hui on a nous aussi des
joueurs cibles qui doivent nous c'est
c'est en l'occurrence c'est carlman pour
cette saison qui doit dire où est-ce
qu'il se déplace où est-ce qu'il est
parce qu'il doit être capable de
répondre à une à une à une demande de de
contrôle à tout moment et je trouve même
si c'est contraignant pour le joueur je
trouve que c'est une bonne chose d'abord
je comprenais pas c'était illogique que
que le C qui soit confronté à ce genre
de de contrainte que c'est bien que ce
soit élargi à tous les sports et que en
terme de en terme de de de de de de
lutte en terme de contrôle c'est une
bonne chose parce que ça veut dire qu'on
intervient à tout moment et et et peu
importe où le joueur se trouve il doit
il doit dire où il est oui c'est
contraignant pour le joueur mais encore
une fois je trouve que c'est c'est c'est
c'est bien en terme de de de de de lutte
contre le
dopage bien donc mais ça commence à être
accepté je le dis parce que je sais que
c'est arrivé de trois fois il a été
contrôlé les joueurs disent c'est
pas normal qu'est-ce que c'est on n pas
de vie privée on peut pas dire où on est
on peut pas dire truc je dis comment on
fait alors comment fait-on pour être
pour être précis pour être donc voilà
c'est une contraite un jour c'est un tel
un jour c'est un tel et puis il y a des
contrôles inopinés on en a eu un nù il y
a peu plus d'un mois 2 mois peut-être
voilà où les gens de la FLD sont venus à
8h du matin et je trouve ça très très
bien voilà ils arrivent ils préviennent
pas ils viennent voilà on voudrait faire
un contrôle tous les joueurs voilà ça ce
sont des choses qui que j'apprécie et
qui montrent bien qu'il y a vraiment un
engagement pour pour lutter et c'est
contrôles
d'unopiné certains pourraient nous dire
il faut les supprimer c'est pas ce que
vous demandez puisque vous nous dites
que vous êtes d'accord pas du tout et
donc qu'il soit inopiné ou qu'il ne le
soit pas c'est l'essentiel c'est de
continuer à avoir des contrôles
exactement lorsque vous étiez memre du
gouvernement est-ce que vous avez senti
dans dans vos relations avec les
fédérations sportives que certaines
était plus engagé plus volontaire que
que d'autres dans cette lutte contre le
dopage non j'ai j'ai senti que bon le
cyclisme c'était particulier eux ils
étaient ils en avaient marre d'être des
vilains canards entre guillemets quoi et
de dire mais je suis sûr qu'il y en a
aussi dans le foot qu' y en a aussi dans
le rugby et ils avaient pas tort de de
dire ça on était pas logé en terme de
contrôle à la même enseigne donc c'est
pour ça qu'on a élargi tout ça mais j'ai
senti sincèrement en France tout le
monde très très concerné par par cette
problématique par contre je le répète
quand j'ai fait mes trois réunions de
Lama j'ai vu des des ministres des sport
qui me disaient mais vous êtes
complètement fou mais qu'est-ce qu'il
qu'est-ce que pourquoi vous en avez
autant après tout ça mais qu'est-ce
qu'on en a à faire ENIT c'était c'était
il y avait des discussions qui étaient
par moment assez assez curieuses quoi et
je me rappelle
notamment à Montréal d'une discussion
avec le un ministre jamaïcain bah qui
lui nous attaquer un petit peu quoi en
disant mais vous voulez jouer à quoi au
justicier donc c'est vrai que quand tu
sors de là tu te dis mais tout le monde
n'est pas la même igne c'est c'est c'est
une évidence en terme de lutte contre le
dopage dans le monde non en France moi
j'ai pas vu une fédération moins engagée
qu'une autre pour
pour dans le contrôle dans le dans la
lutte contre le dopage non j'ai senti
tous les gens concernés et puis je
dirais les les les les institutions ça
ça c'est tellement nuisible quand
quelque chose sort que que les
présidents tout le monde et tout le
monde est solidaire et tout le monde
fait en sorte que ça fonctionne
bien
al nry souhaite poser une question merci
simplement c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant deter bien dans la porte
parce qu'il a eu
plusieurs casquettes il a été entraîneur
de l'équipe de France après ministre
donc il a été au contact de la réalitéc
du sport de haut niveau mais également
certainement avec les jeunes des centres
de formation donc moi je suis très
heureux de ce que vous venez de nous
dire parce c'est une des questions que
je vouis vous poser par rapport au
contrôle inopiné parce que j'ai écouté
dire que dans les sports collectifs en
particulier dans le rugby on était dire
que c'était pas normal qu'on qu'il a des
contrôles inopinés donc si un entraîneur
de votre niveau et de vos
responsabilités dis que c'est bien moi
je suis très satisfait parce que ça veut
dire que vous luttez pour qu'il les
contrôle d'opiné au rugby comme dans
toutes la discipline sportive pour que
tout le monde soit traité à égalité je
voudrais seulement vous dire une chose
qui ce qui m'inquiète un peu c'est que
il y a de plus en plus de matchs de
rugby les calendriers deviennent quand
même des mentiel même si certaines
équipes ont des ban suffisants pour
faire enroulement mais enfin bon il y a
des deuxè le rythme de jeu est assez
étonnant quand on a l'habitude de suivre
le Ruby depuis plusieurs années on
s'aperçoit que le nombre de minutes joué
effectiv a considérablement augmenté la
vitesse est assez exceptionnelle les la
violence des des contacts est quand même
aussi parfois inquiétante parfois
inquiétante et tout ça est lié au
changement de morphologie des joueurs
est-ce que le changement de morphologie
des joueurs vous inquiète pas pouvant
être signe avantcoureur peut-être de
quelques pratiques qui ne soi pas tout à
fait naturell et qu'on pourra assimiler
du
dopage oui oui c'est c'est une bonne
question effectivement quand on regarde
on va pas parler de de de de très très
longtemps de rugby mais aujourd'hui un
match un match de très très bon très
très niveau c'est c'est 40 minutes de
temps de jou effectif c'est pendant 40
minutes le ballon est en jeu quoi donc
effectivement pour pour comparer quand
je jouais c'était 20 23 minutes quoi et
c'était quand même en 91 c'était pas il
y a y a 50 ans quoi donc la mor
morphologie tout a tout a évolué d'abord
ils sont professionnels ils s'ent
trînent tous les jours ils font ils font
beaucoup de musculation que ce soit
l'intersaison que ce soit durant la
saison donc aujourd'hui on a on a
affaire à à des joueurs athlètes que
nous n'étions pas nous à l'époque nous à
l'époque il y avait des joueurs de rugby
des vitement qu'on appelit ça mais on il
y en avait certains athlètes mais il y
en avait d'utres qui étaient pas du tout
des athlètes de de haut niveau
aujourd'hui ce sont tous des athlète et
c'est marrant parce ce matin Christophe
domci est passé à l'entraînement à
l'entraînement de Toulon et il regardait
les les et certains joueurs il disaient
mais tu as vu comment ils sont fabriqués
maintenant alors Christophe il jouit il
y a christop Dom jouit encore il y a il
y a quelques temps il me dit j'ai joué à
la bonne époque j'ai fait quand même
christop il a encore des gens de ton
gabarit heureusement mais c'est vrai
c'est surtout derrière que que ça évolue
quand on regarde on parlait tout à
l'heure donc avec le SAL de son équipe
de cler montferran le physique des
joueurs de de cler Monferran mais mais
quand on regarde ce sont souvent si on
prend le cas de de de Nalaga ou de
siatou bon ce sont des gens qui viennent
des îles et ces gens des îles ils ont
cette morphologie ils sont costauds ils
sont voilà ils sont sont ils sont ils
sont différents c'est c'est une évidence
mais encore une fois c'est plus lié à
leur à leur naturel et le travail bien
sûr à côté ça c'est une évidence qu'
qu'à la moindre suspicion de dopage ça
j'en suis entièrement convaincu puis on
s'aperçoit quand on regarde l'imag de
Super 15 mais que ces gens des îles ils
ont ils ont toujours eu des physiques
différentes des nôtres mais on a nous
aussi à Tahiti et cetera des gens qui
ont des physiques qui ont des physiques
hors norme et c'est pas pour ça qu'il
faut jetter le discrédit mais c'est vrai
que dans le rugby il y a de plus en plus
de joueurs c'est tellement devenu un jeu
qui ressemble de plus en plus au jeu à
13 où la perte du ballon est à un contre
un est interdite bien que du du 1 au 15
il faut être capable d'affronter deux
défenseurs et pas perdre le ballon je
crois que c'est les grandes équipes et
clairement en est une sa grande force
c'est que tous les joueurs du 1 au 15
dès qu'ils affrontent la défense il
perdent rarement le ballon quo c'est une
évidence et dans les équipes qui
rencontrent
régulièrement les équipes françaises pas
l'équipe de France les équipes
françaises quand on regarde les joueurs
anglais ce sont pas spécialement des
gens qui ont une taille de minime ou de
Cadet oui c'est un compliment comme
ça Dominique Bay oui monsieur le
ministre je voudrais vous interroger sur
l'encadrement des clubs aujourd'hui
parce que on l'a évoqué en 2012 deux
joueurs de Toulon que vous entraînez
aujourd'hui ont été ont été contrôlés
bon ils ont été blanchis
on a appris que c'était le tout bip de
l'équipe qui leur avait donné bon moi ce
qui m'interpelle c'est
que comment se fait-il qu'un un médecin
d'équipe qui est aussi je crois médecin
de l'équipe de franceant oui maintenant
et pu
donner ces médicaments qui
tombaient sous le coup de la loi puisque
c'était bref mécanisme c'était de la
morphine qui se retrouvait dans
l'organisme donc moi ça ça m'interpelle
me dit parce que j'ai entendu vous nous
avez dit oui la Fédération les ligues
sont déterminés pour lutter contre le
dopage mais est-ce que c'est pas un peu
léger comme pratique ça non en fait bon
moi je suis pas encore une fois un
technicien de la médecine en ce cas bien
particulier donc c'est le docteur Risoli
qui était le médecin de Toulon à
l'époque et qui aujourd'hui est le
médecin de l'équipe de France
effectivement qui avait donné des
produits codéinés à des joueurs mais un
joueur vous lu dites il faut en prendre
deux si sent qu'il a toujours mal il en
prendre 3è le docteur lui dit pas
attention la dégradation de ces de ces
de ces de ce produit fait que si tu en
prends plusieurs il va y avoir une
dégradation etonn
ouais non mais c'est pas un produit d'an
c'est un produit autorisé qu' lu a donné
c'est la dégradation de ce produit qui
fait que ça ça ça ça contribue à 15 %
d'un produit don je ne sais le nom qui
lui est un produit interdit mais c'est
la dégradation du produit codiné qui a
fait ça donc jamais un médecin va donner
un produit dopin c'est pas possible
c'est alors après il faut jamais dire
jamais c'est effectivement vous pouvez
tomber sur un médecin qui dit un joueur
parce que le joueur il est comme moi il
il les connait s'il lu dit ti prend ça
et que c'est un produit d'Opin il il va
pas lui dire ça peut arriver ça qu'on
soit d'accord mais en fait il prend une
responsabilité énorme aujourd'hui le
médecin qui qui qui fait ça c'est c'est
on sait que l'encadrement aujourd'hui
qualité l'encadrement de qualité partout
et puis bon un médecin c'est un médecin
il a une carrière à gérer je veux dire
on n'est pas euh il il a pas fini sa vie
mais quand il quand il entraîne un club
il a il a derrière une carrière
professionnelle assuré imaginez-vous que
ce soit quelqu'un qui donné un produit
dopin je crois que sa carrière
professionnelle elle en prendrait
véritablement un coup alors après euh
oui on peut tomber sur quel sur sur Ben
sur sur un fou ça peut arriver faut pas
faut pas faut jamais dire jamais hein
sur on fou qui prend le risque et qui
dit je prends ça c'est autorisé puis
c'est interdit et le joueur il il sait
pas ça c'est c'est une évidence aussi
hein Stéphan
loisard monsieur le ministre la semaine
dernière donc il y a eu une déclaration
de Laurent
benzch dans le le monde donc qui disait
je le cite et le rugby dans la situation
du cyclisme avant l'affaire
fistina
réaction je trouve que c'est grave de de
de de si si dire des choses comme ça
s'il en a des preuves alors qu'ils
disent ça qu'il parlent mais qu'il
amèent des preuves c'est facile de de de
jeter le discrédit sur des choses sans
savoir le Comand c'est c'est moi je
trouve que c'est je trouve ça lâche
voilà pour vous dire pour vous dire la
vérité je trouve que c'est c'est que
c'est vraiment lâche parce que s'il
vivait avec les clubs professionnels
dont je fais partie ça c'est vrai que ce
qui dit n'existe pas et que ce soit avec
l'équipe de France ça existe ça existe
pas du tout non plus que je sache donc
comment peut-il dire ça comment peut-il
dire ça voilà qu'il apporte des preuves
c'est facile de de de de de toujours
dire de de de faire l'intéressant
permettz-moi l'expression mais avec qui
qu' apporte des preuves voilà c'est trop
trop facile de dire ça mais c'est grave
ça c'est ça rassemble à faire fesa c'est
c'est ça veut dire que s'il dit ça ça
veut dire qu'il a des preuves alors
qu'il qu'il les apporte et à ce
moment-là euh on rera non je trouve je
trouve ça de lâche ridicule je sais même
pas le terme qu'il faut employer
quoi donc dans ce dans ce combat de
première ligne entre serge Simon et
Laurent benzche vous êtes résolument du
côté de serge Simon et sur le terrain je
préféis déjà jouer avec seron plutôt que
Benz pour vous dire la
vérité oui tout tout tout à l'heure
monsieur le sénateur nerry l'a abordé
mais euh est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous vous
considérez que le rythme qui est imposé
hein le le calendrier qui est imposé
donc au au club de rugby et notamment au
club qui participent aux compétitions
européennes et dont les joueurs
participent aux compétitions
internationales avec le maillot de
l'équipe de France est-ce que ça vous
semble encore compatible quand même avec
une pratique saine
sportive ça me semble ça me semble
compatible oui à condition à condition
comme disait le sénateur Néry mais
d'avoir des effectifs euh plétorique
comme comme comme comme Clermont là
comme tous là comme nous on peut on peut
l'avoir aussi sans quoi c'est impossible
c'est c'est c'est une évidence quand on
parle le match de de que nous avons
livré dimanche contre leisterter je peux
vous garantir que jqu jusqu'à ce matin à
l'entraînement j'avais rarement vu les
joueurs de toulom fatigué comme ça déjà
on s'est pas entraîné lundi mardi on a
fait que de la récupération parce que je
sentais que et même les préparateur
physiques me disaient ce matin à la
muscu il me disait Bernard on va réduire
30 % parce que je sens qu' c'est ça
manque de de d'appétit ça manque
d'enthousiasme ils étaient encore encore
émousé mais des matchs comme ça et je
dis ça sans prétention on a ressort é
moussé quand on joue Toulouse quand on
joue quand on va jouer clermon quand on
va jouer le Racing heureusement si tous
les matchs étaient de l'intensité qu'on
a livré dimanche alors je vous le dis de
suite ce serait impossible même avec un
effectif plétorique heureusement qu'il y
a la saison des matchs plus faciles
c'est c'est une évidence parce que des
matchs comme dimanche on peut pas en
livrer 40 dans la saison c'est
impossible ça
impossible on va pas quitter le domaine
de du sport mais on va quitter un moment
le domaine du
rugby vous avez été à l'origine d'un
texte de loi
sur le trafic de produits d'pan sûr euh
estimez-vous que les les nouvelles
incriminations pénales qui résultent de
ce texte voté par le Parlement que ces
nouvelles incriminations créé ont fait
leur preuve
et pensez-vous que la coordination
entre les douanes la
FLD
l'OC
sont efficace aujourd'hui
oui c'était quoi ce ce ce ce ce
complément de loi sur le dopage c'était
qu'effectivement il y av eu l'affaire
rasmusen ou la femme de de de de de de
de ce coureur cycliste mais c'est elle
qui transportait tous les tous les
produits non c'était rasmusen de mémoire
ah bon bons fa je croyais que c'était
rasmusen bon et
effectivement oui oui non mais je je
fais confiance au
sénateur et donc on avait dit mais c'est
quand même c'est quand même illogique
que cette dame qui a été pris donc on
avait ouvert son capot en tout le monde
avait vu qu'il y avait des produuit d'OP
puis elle non non après tout voilà elle
se promenait elle suivait son mari quoi
suivait les étapes et on avait dit mais
s y a quelque chose qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas logique donc on avait
effectivement rectifié un petit peu la
loi et dit ben toute personne qui sera
prise en train de transporter des
produits d'pin sera aussi susceptible de
de de de de de peine donc est-ce qu'elle
est-ce qu'elle a fait ses preuves j'ai
pas entendu à aujourd'hui de personnees
pris un flagrant d'lit de transporter
des produits d'opan à côté d'une course
cycliste ou d'un match de de de rugby ou
de foot et cetera je pense quand même
qu'elle fait peur c'est une c'est une
évidence et mais bon dire qu'elle est
parfaite que qu'il y aura jamais rien
encore une fois certainement pas mais il
fallait faire en sorte qu'elle soit
qu'elle soit améliorée et je suis
convaincu quand même que ça que ça ça
fait peur
certainement à des gens qui qui le
faisaient à l'époque qui le font
plus permis de ralentir sur le plan du
trafic un certain nombre de choses
inavoables qui se produisait ici ou là
oui oui ça ça a aidé c'est une
évidence le rapporteur
oui monsieur le ministre dans dans la
lutte
antiopage est-ce que vous croyez est-ce
que vous pensez il faut responsabiliser
davantage les fédérations sportives
parce que bon au fil de nos auditions on
a eu des des positions très différentes
pour ne pas dire diamétralement opposé
sur le sujet certains disant que il
fallait une coupure nette une scission
radicale entre la lutte contre le dopage
et le mouvement sportif qui pouvait pas
être à la fois jugé et parti ou alors
dans le domaine de la prévention mais
seulement dans le domaine de la
prévention et puis ceux qui au contraire
nous disent qu'il faut absolument
impliquer davantage le Boubon sportif
moi je suis pour l'impliquer davantage
c'est une évidence et en terme de
prévention surtout mais c'est pas trop
les fédérations c'est surtout les ligues
en ce qui concerne les sports
professionnels qui sont concerné nous
les les gens de la Fédération on on les
voit jamais nous on appartient à une
ligue donc effectivement que ça passe
par la Fédération oui parce que c'est
quand même uneinstitution majeure mais
que ça redescende par les ligues et
qu'en terme de prévention il y ait
effectivement des reportings des
réunions entre médecin et cetera et
cetera pour pour faire en sorte bien que
que tout soit clair que que que les
informations euh passe bien moi je suis
convaincu qu'il faut que le mouement
sportif fasse partie intégrante de de de
de de cette de cette
prévention lors de votre intervention
liminaire vous avez évoqué les quelques
réunions auxquell vous avez participé à
Lama avez-vous ressenti des divergences
et si vous ou lesquelles entre les
anglo-saxons et et la France au sujet du
dopage pas trop avec pas trop avec les
anglo-saxons mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que j'ai j'ai j'ai comme je le disais
j'ai pas ressenti que la lutte contre le
dopage était une priorité dans tous les
pays ça c'est ça c'est ça c'est clair
quoi et que on était pour certains les
les je le répète les Villain canard quoi
en disant mais qu'est-ce que vous avez
le dopage entre guillemets
permettezation qu av nous gonfler avec
le avec avec le dopage vous voulez jouer
au justicier vous voulez jouer à quoi
donc nous on est un pays leader on le je
le disais on le dit et on continue à
l'être c'est bien j'ai toujours senti
les anglosaxons à nos côtés j'ai jamais
senti trop de de de de de division entre
entre nous mais bon quand on va dans ce
genre de réunion vous savez il y a y a a
il y a 150 pays donc on parlez pas avec
tout le monde mais quand les gens
prennent prennent la parole
effectivement à certain moment vous êtes
vous êtes vous êtes un petit peu ouais
choqué de certaines interventions o des
gens disent qu'on va trop loin dans la
lutte contre le dopage oui on n pas en
phase mondialement c'est une évidence
est-ce que vous pouvez pas le sport he
qu'on est pas en
face bien d'accord on parle de sport et
on parle de dopage de lutte contre le
dopage vous avez le sentiment
que au-delà des appréciations que vous
venez de porté rapidement je respecte le
fait que vous les ayez été rapide c'est
le but du jeu mais pourriez-vous nous en
dire plus sur ceux qui étaient rétiscent
non mais c'est je vous répète c'est
c'est délicat de dire moi je me rappelle
avoir eu avoir une discussion avec avec
le ministre jamaïcain qui qui qui
comprenait pas quoi notre notre notre
notre virul
notre engagement
si si forcé quoi donc oui j'ai bien
compris que chez lui c'était pas c'était
pas une priorité ça c c'est une évidence
après je répète on parle pas on parle
pas avec tout le monde mais j'ai vu
différentes interventions différents
ministres o pareil je sentais dans le
dans leur propos et cetera oui il faut
lutter contre le dopage mais il faut pas
non
plus le faire de façon engagée comme on
peut le faire nous
mais tout le monde n'a pas aussi y a un
problème de moyens aussi après c'est
quand on veut lutter contre le dopage il
faut des moyens financiers et autres
eteffectivement il y a certains pays qui
ne les ont pas et donc qui font le
strict
minimum pensez-vous puisque vous parlez
de moyens que les moyens consacrés
actuellement dans notre pays à la lutte
contre le dopage sont suffisants
insuffisants normau pour qu'on peut
faire faudrail faire plus Mo si j'ai
faittat de mes discussions avecer plus
là qui était l'ancien patron de la FLD
il y a pas assez de moyens ça c'était
chaque fois que je voyais c'était ça
monsieur ministre il me faut d'autres
moyens mais quand les quand les moyens
sont sont justifiés sincèrement il faut
les donner voilà la de contô de page il
faut qu'elle reste une priorité donc
puisque vous évoquez la FLD les moyens
consacrés actuellement son Borderie
insuffisant permett de faire du bon
travail je sais pas c'est eux qu'il faut
le dire j'ai aucune idée moi moi je moi
je m'en rappelle à l'époque
il y avait eu une discussion sur sur une
baisse de budget bon pierre brer était
venu à la charge de trois fois en disant
attention ministre moi j'ai besoin de si
pour ça pour ça pour ça j'avais dit
faisons un effort et continuons à faire
en sorte que la FLD ait le même budget
puisque apparemment c'est c'est justifié
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas s'il a baissé
s'il a augmenté s'ils sont contents ou
pas c'est à eux qu' faut poser la
question mais à l'époque on travaillait
je dirais si je vous dis main dans la
main c'était le but quand même on peut
pas demander un organisme il faut être
bon dans l contre le dopage et si vous
vous lui si vous lu couper les moyens
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas possible
une question se
pose selon moi j'ai peut-être tort l'AMA
c'est une agence
mondiale la FLD en
France dans le cadre de cette
construction européenne remise en cause
ici et là il y aurait-il selon vous
l'obligation de créer un échelon en
matière de lutte antiopage au niveau
européen ou est-ce que les moyens de la
FLD une part de laamas de l'autre sont
suffisants pour lutter contre le dopage
non moi je pense que un échelon
intermédiaire effectivement européen une
agence européenne de lutte contre le
dommage ne serait pas de trop d'abord
elle permettrait de faire en sorte que
les informations convergent que tout le
monde travaille
dans avec avec les mêmes avec les mêmes
principes mais quand on avait fait le le
Conseil des ministres informés la biarit
les 27 et 28 novembre de mémoire
2000 2008 quand n quand nous avions la
présidence de de de de de l'Union
européenne c'est un point qui avait été
évoqué les 27 ministres étaient là et on
avait évoqué effectivement cette cette
possibilité de se regrouper de
travailler plus ensemble et et et créer
cette agence
elle n'a à mes yeux enfin à ma
connaissance pardon elle n'a pas elle
n'existe pas mais mais c'est vrai que ce
serait c'est c'est ce que eux avent
évoqué parce que si je ne sais plus quel
est le ministre qui l'avait évoqué me
semblait être une une une une bonne
chose
merci Dominique Baili oui je voudrais
avoir votre sentiment sur le passeport
biologique parce que effectivement il y
a les contrôles inopiné mais on voit
bien
que ce serait plutôt sur le long terme
et en amont qu'il faut contrôler alors
le passeport biologique sa
généralisation est-ce que vous pensez
que ça va dans le bon sens est-ce que
c'est
globalement applicable dans tout les
sports d'ailleurs pas que le rugby dans
tous les sports on sait que certains
sports certaines fédérations se sont
sont moteur d'autres moins mais est-ce
qu'il faudrait aller encore plus loin
avec ce passeport biologique ou moi
quand je suis arrivé au au gouvernement
donc en octobre 2007 Ros bachelo venait
justement de de d'entériner le passeport
biologique et je me rappelle le premier
soir lundi soir on avait un un dîner au
C OSF et que sincèrement quand on quand
on regarde les bienfaits du passeport
biologique on peut pas être contre c'est
ça serait stupide d'être contre alors de
là dire que ce soit
euh là aussi réalisé par toutes les
fédérations oui pourquoi pas mais mais
là aussi ça va demander des moyens des
moyens considérables à partir du moment
où on met quelque chose en place qui va
lutter il faut pas dire non c'est pas
bien et surtout si ça marche bien estce
qu' aujourd'hui c'est quand même l' mais
mais on est d'accord sécuris c'est le
plus sécurisant et vous allez me dire
c'est surtout les cyclistes qui sont
confrontés ou mais tous les sports le
tennis le rugby je pense que si on
mettait le passort moi je suis moi je
suis pour à partir du moment où c'est
pour excusez-moi d'in sur un tout petit
point détail désident le micro parce que
oui non ben je pour oui moi je pense
qu'effectivement enfin je vrais avoir
votre sentiment que la l'application
concrète du passeport biologique dans
tous les sports pourrait être une
réponse même si effectivement ça coûte
cher mais c'est une volonté politique
bien sû parce que c'est quoi un
passeport biologique c'est on fait votre
état physiologique est là et donc dès
qu'il est suivi il faut pas qu'il y ait
de de de grandes perturbations sans quoi
effectivement on peut dire donc à partir
du moment c'est un contrôle dans la
continuité ça me ça me semble être une
une très bonne chose et si tout le monde
pouvait le faire et si toutes les
fédérations pouvaent pouvaient
l'utiliser j'y suis favorable encore une
fois combien ça coûte à mon avis c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est là
la question mais autrement oui bien sûr
que j suis
favorable merci euh seul rapporteur oui
la la lutte antiopage donc c'est une
question de de moyens c'est vrai mais
c'est aussi une question de de finalité
d'objectif donc en France on est dans un
système où l'objectif c'est la tolérance
zéro hein donc ça veut dire une
politique d'éradication en quelque sorte
à partir d'une liste de de produits
interdits est-ce que d'après vous il
faut rester vraiment sur cette position
là d'intransigence si je peux dire ou
alors aller vers telle ou telle
tolérance tel ou tel assouplissement moi
je pense qu'il faut être intransigent
parce que si on commence à être tolérant
alors on va au devant de de de de de de
beaucoup de problèmes c'est une évidence
et on parlait de de mon sport tout à
l'heure où effectivement certains se
posent des questions parce que suite à
certaines discussions qui sont sont
sortis tout le monde s'inquiète un petit
peu dans le monde rubbi tout le monde
commence à dire mais tout façon ils sont
si costaud c'est parce qu'il c'est parce
qu'ils se dopent donc moi tolérance zéro
je crois qu'encore une fois on est on
peut pas avoir fait 10 pas en avant et
dire maintenant on va en faire deux en
arrière parce que d'abord on serait pas
crédible ça c'est la première des choses
et deuxièmement là oui on serait
confronté à à beaucoup de problèmes je
crois qu'il y a il y a un sentiment de
peur aussi qui doit exister et dire que
la tolérance zéro ça sera la tolérance
zéro et que les joueurs doivent prendre
le responsabilité dire sil faute ben il
n'y aura pas de il y aura pas de cadeau
comme on dit dans la sanction elle doit
être
imminente et
importante une question sur les sportifs
repentis sportifs repentis effectivement
c'est une situation un peu particulière
qui d'ailleurs n'est pas envisagée dans
le droit français c'est-à-dire cette
sorte de donnant donnant entre d'un côté
vous faites des révélations et puis on
va alléger votre peine bon est-ce que
vous croyez qu' est-ce que vous pensez
que dans un futur texte il faut se
pencher sur cette question là est-ce
qu'il faut les impliquer d'avant
avantage ou bien est-ce qu'il faut
rester très très prudent non non là je
suis pas du tout
pour donc vous êtes très méfiant mais
sûr
mais c'est c'est pas c'est la délation
d'abord c'est quelque chose qui est pas
beau et de non je encore une
fois continuons dans ce que nous avons
engagé il y a pas besoin de de de de de
de de joueurs de cors repenti je crois
qu'encore une
fois les choses sont sur le bon chemin
et et je vois pas pourquoi on
utiliserait des proc des principes qui
moi me déplaisent par contre
là dans la lutte contre le dopage telle
qu'elle est organisée réalisée
aujourd'hui si vous
aviez quelques responsabilités
ministérielle encore quels sont les
points que vous jugeriez
indispensable sur lesquels vous
penseriez devoir agir pour pour
améliorer la lutte contre le dopage
avez-vous en clair des regrets pour
faute de temps de de
moyens politique au sens général du
terme des regrets tels que vous pourriez
suggérer à vos successeurs aujourd'hui
ministre ou demain ministre des Sports
de se lancer plutôt sur telle ou telle
piste pour améliorer la lutte contre le
dopage non je je serai pour que
justement la FLD est encore plus de
moyens et et je serais pour beaucoup
plus de contrôle inopiné personnellement
ça me gêne pas du tout
voilà qu'on montre bien que que que
tolérance zéro beaucoup de contrôle
beaucoup de
suivi mais après
effectivement dire oui mais c'est pas la
même chose dans tous les pays bah j'ai
entendu des sportifs de de de à Pékin
qui qui me disaient mais c'est bien de
lutter contre le dopage mais vous savez
on va concourir contre des gens dont la
lutte contre le dopage est moins et
moins importante on a des doutes on a
c'est pas grave continuons continu à
avoir des doutes et et faire faitesvous
battre par ces gens-là s'ils sont si
s'il passent à travers des mailles mais
c'est encore une fois c'est une question
de de de de principe d'honneur voilà
faisons en sorte de lutter encore plus
et et si j'avais un conseil à donner
c'est ben encore plus de moyens encore
plus de
contrôle c'est clair Alan Derry oui moi
j'ai bien écouté Bernard la porte semble
convaincu que il y a pas de souci que
tout va bien dans le meilleur des mondes
pour ce qui concerne sa discipline et
peut-être d'autres discipl
mais ça m'empêche pas d'être quand même
inquiet et là je m'adresse à
l'entraîneur beaucoup de joueurs de
jeunes joueurs avec des qualités
physiques
indéiables je trouve mais que ils sont
quand même un peu souvent blessé un peu
souvent blessé et que le développement
morphologique certes vous avez parlé à
juste titre des des gens qui viennent
des îles des Samois et ailleurs mais on
a quand même vu des joueurs français
changer de morphologie rapidement en
prenant 13 14 kg de muscle en un an
est-ce que ça vous inquiète pas est-ce
que vous pensez pas que c'est un peu
beaucoup et deuxièmement que ces
blessures répétition deviennent
inquiétantes pour la
longévité le pont a fait la prospérité
des Rê si en le pont vous n'auriez pas
de collège vous n'auriez pratiquement
plus d'école plus de permanence ça a
permis de penser à un avenir où on
pourrait peut-être s'installer ici en
1980 28 le destin de l'île- de Ray a
basculé avec la et j'avais dit je pas
que vous fiez pas des vieux même
oui moi je vais parler de ce que je
connais des blessures des joueurs
qui souvent blessés si je prends le cas
de de de Toulon il y a pas un joueur
Hori un jeune espoir qui malheureusement
c'est
encore flingué les croisés ce ce weekend
c'est la deuxème fois en 1 an je je on
peut pas dire à tout l'OM par exemple il
y un joueur qui est toujours blessé ça
c'est pas vrai je vois pas à clamont
Ferrand un joueur toujours blessé
interrogation oui non non j'ai bien
compris donc dire que notre sport est
devenu de plus en plus physique de plus
en plus athlétique entre guillemets de
plus en plus violent au sens noble du
terme ça c'est une évidence ça c'est
certain c'est devenu de 10 fois plus
engagé que ce que ça ne l'était mais je
ressens pas de joueurs souvent blessés
non c'est fait c'est pas quelque chose
qui me
frappe si je peux me permettre président
ça veut dire que vous avez pas de cinte
quand à l'intégrité physique des joueur
pour le pour la suite si si par contre
ce qui est sûr c'est que je sais pas si
nous on va faire des vilains vieux mais
eux par contre avec ceux qui se mettent
t tous les dimanche c'est sûr que des
matchs comme dimanche que ce soit le
vôtre ou que ce soit le nôre ben quand
il y a un tel engagement que tu te dis
oui c'est ça va ça va ça va laisser les
traces mais mais ils sont tellement
protégés aussi quand on voit la
morphologie des joueurs aujourd'hui
c'est que bon il ils ont tel carapace
que ça AMORC c'est bon c'est c'est c'est
lié c'est l'entraînement qui fait
l'intensité du jeu aussi si aujourd'hui
y a autant d'intensité c'est parce qu'il
y a encore plus d'entraînement qui vont
encore plus vite encore ils sont encore
plus puissants c'est c'est lié
l'entraînement et et l'intensité que
reproduite sur le terrain donc oui ils
feront certainement des vilain vieux
mais on le voit moi je vois certains
piliers qui aujourd'hui à 30 ans ont du
mal ont du mal à se tourner il y en a
chez nous hein parce que voilà parce que
les Mlé mais mais je me rappelle à
l'époque les Serges Simon Philippe
gembert et autres mais il y avait
certains lundis où ils arrivaient comme
ça
aussi monsieur le rapporteur
oui
euh le le le weekend dernier il y a eu
un collocque organisé par le CNOSF sur
sur le dopage et euh il y a eu donc
semble-t-il une intervention du médecin
de la Fédération Française de de rugby
qui a évoqué un un comportement assez
suspect assez douteux d'autant plus que
des enquêtes sembl en cours euh à savoir
que il interviendrait comme cette
personne hein interviendrait comme
préparateur
physique donc en individuel si je peux
dire auprès de rugbyan est-ce que ça
existe ça ou est-ce que c'est le club
qui a un ou des préparateurs physiques
pour les joueurs de l'équipe enfin des
équipes ou bien est-ce que un rugbyman
peut avoir à côté du préparateur
physique de son club un autre
préparateur physique avec qui il a passé
une sorte de de contrat bien sûr que ça
peut ça peut ça peut
exister ce qui concerne les clubs
l'organisation elle est simple il y a un
staff de préparation physique nous on a
trois personnes qui qui ont en charge la
préparation physique de nos joueurs à ma
connaissance personne ne va voir
d'autres préparations physiquees parce
que ça se passe bien avec les nôtres
mais mais vous dire qu'un jour il y en a
un qui ira voir pe parre physique à Nice
parce que parce qu'il le connaît bien
qu'il a plus confiance à lui et qu' va
lui faire des des séquences
supplémentaires je je faut pas dire non
parce que ça peut ça peut ça peut
arriver à tout moment effectivement je
je je je je sais de quoi vous parlez et
et de la personne et des joueurs c'est
des joueurs que j'avais en équipe de
France moi à l'époque qui allaient voir
PAP physique qui était autrre que leur
que le physique de leur club mais quand
je parlais avec eux euh j'ai dit écoutez
il y a des suspicions quand même et
cetera et cetera et eux étaient
catégorique en me disant mais il y a
aucune suspicion nous on a confiance en
ce mec parce qu'il nous fait faire des
des des exercices que notre partte
physique ne nous fait pas faire et nous
on se sent mieux quand on fait ces
exercices là et cetera et cetera c'était
plus un rapport de confiance que que que
qu'autre chose al je sais que ça ça
engendrait plein de doutes parce qu'en
plus cette personne là s'est retrouvé
vendant des compléments alimentaires et
autres alors bien sûr qu'il faut être
rigoureux bien sûr qu'il faut faire
attention et bien sûr que je joueur
attention vous êtes moi vous n'êtes pas
connaisseur dans tout cela donc prenez
prenez des précautions quand même n'y
allez pas les yeux euh mais bon sur ce
qu'il me disaient eux non non il y avait
aucun souci et puis que je sache ces
joueurs là pour ne pas les citer ils
n'ont jamais été ils ont été contrôlés
comme tout le monde il y a jamais rien
eu donc là aussi faisons attention de ne
pas jeter le discrédit tant qu'on a pas
de preuve tant que le jour on me dira
ben ce préparateur physique a vendu des
produits alimentaires à tel joueurs il a
été pris pour dopage alors oui on pourra
dire il faut le il faut le il faut le
discréditer aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas
ça ça a été que des rumeurs et
sincèrement derrière il y a rien eu mais
mais pour répondre à la question bien
sûr que ça peut arriver qu'un joueur est
un intervenant extérieur qu'il paye même
ça peut ça peut ça peut très bien
arriver c'est une
évidence une une question sur la
justement la la pénalisation ou pas de
l'usage des produits d'pan c'est-à-dire
ajouter en quelque sorte à la sanction
sportive une sanction pénale pour
l'athlète concerné est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à cette pénalisation
oui oui et non je dirais si si c'est
quelque chose qui
est faut faire attention là aussi c'est
c'est est-ce que est-ce que c'est à
l'insu du joueur c'est ce que c'est ce
que je c'est ce que je veux dire si si
on sait que que c'est organisé que le
joueur sait et cetera et cetera c'est
évident si c'est quelque chose où où le
joueur il peut avoir aussi des
faiblesses il a confiance en quelqu'un
qui lu donne des compléments
alimentaires il se rend pas compte que
c'est ces complément alimentaires on Tom
pourpan qui fait qu'il est qu'il est
pris il y a il y
a pour moi il y a deux étapes quoi si
c'est vraiment quelque chose de de de de
programmé
de de connu par le par le par le
champion enfin par le par par le sportif
bien sûr qu'il faut que ce soit pénal
parce que c'est c'est c'est un acte
volontaire c'est un acte délibéré c'est
quelque chose si c'est quelque chose qui
est fait un petit peu comme comme dis
certain euh contre ça contre sa sa
connaissance surtout il faut être plus
plus plus oui son pleingé j'allais dire
ben il faut être plus plus
indulgent chers
collègues qu'auriez-vous souhaiter nous
dire sur la base des questions que vous
nous avons posé mais surtout sur la base
des questions que nous nous avons pas
posé non vous dire queessage
principal que vous souhaitez que nous
retenions que c'est bien que vous
intéressiez à ce genre de problème voilà
que que que que que le Sénat
se organise des commissions d'enquête
sur contre le dopage et cetera et cetera
c'est c'est d'abord ça ça je trouve que
ça c'est un honneur pour le sport en
général et que qu'il faut continuer
voilà il faut le faire savoir voilà que
que que vous savez dans la tête des
sportifs quand je leur ai
dit que j'allais être commissionné
certains joueurs qui m'ont dit mais il
s'up pourquoi il s'occupe de ça les
politiques attendez mais les politiques
il font les lois c'est c'est c'est eux
qui font les lois donc quand vous êtes
contrôlé ça arrive pas comme ça des
trucs et donc encore une fois oui c'est
c'est bien que vous le que vous le
fassiez et et même si c'est contraignant
de venir entre deux matchs importants et
cetera il faut qu'on vienne c'est pour
ça j'ai dit oui je serai là je viendrai
parce que voilà il faut montrer aussi
qu'on est tous en phase et que et qu'on
est tous déterminés à faire en sorte que
que cette lutte elle
continue merci Monsieur le Ministre
merci à vous d'avoir répondu à à notre
invitation mais merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions et puis euh il parait que
ça se fait pas en sport je ne dis rien
pour les matchs à venir j'en pense pas
moi voilà pour les travaux de la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale sur le
dopage si vous souhaitez en savoir plus
ou revoir ces auditions notre site
internet publsenat.fr bonne journée à
tous
le pont a fait la prospérité des r sur
le pont